we are going to get going even though
Representatives Davis is over
introducing a bill
representative Kelly is out sick
attending to a bunch of sick people in
so why don't we begin
by having
representative Brown lead us in the
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
ah
okay ask the clerk to call the roll
please
foreign
power
present
representative Guthrie
representative Joe Keller
representative Kelly
representative Elwood here
representative Brown here representative
Cahill
here
representative Davis
representative chair 11 representative
Gilman here
representative majority here
representative
representative Gallagher here
representative Hicks here representative
Howland here representative Pierce
priests here sorry
and uh chairman turcott
here
normally that's a ten dollar fine that
gets donated to a uh
charity at the end of the season but
we'll
okay we'll go ahead and uh open up uh
hearing on HB 489 I have
nobody signed in and I have one pink
so I'm here today to introduce this bill
HB 489 as well as an amendment to it
which is
2023-0238h which I've handed out copies
to everyone
my original bill
as you have copies of that as well
my original Bill sought to set up a new
fund managed by business and economic
Affairs Bea
to help fund New Hampshire counties with
grant money to be used for County
tourism development
in the original bill
money to fund this initiative would have
come from the rooms and meals tax
this has all been changed after
conversations with Bea commissioner
Taylor Caswell and travel and tourism
director Lori harnois
they had a better idea and thought to
expand their existing joint promotional
program the jpp
by adding an Operational Support Program
I've also handed out copies of the
original statute that includes or that
has the language for the joint
promotional program
so we came up with this amendment that I
have before you to the original bill
which creates this new Operational
Support Program modeled after the jpp
this amendment changes the entire bill
and the name of the bill has also been
changed
this new program managed through Bea
would make grant money available to
County governments to assist with
operational costs of their tourism
development efforts
currently Counties have no means to
obtain financial help from Bea for
County tourism development programs
because they're not eligible for the jpp
program
this will be a great help to counties to
develop and expand their tourism and
help businesses and the county tax base
grow as a result
this will ultimately bring in more
Revenue to the state
I hope you can see the value to County
government in this new program
and pass this bill with its Amendment
and I'd be happy to ask answer any
questions that you have
thank you representative Ahrens just to
be clear for everybody here we are
looking at
yes there was another amendment that uh
representative Aaron had sent to
everybody and the difference between the
two amendments is the elimination of one
sentence
could you show explain uh tell us which
sentence sure
um
I have copies of the old Amendment if
you'd like me to hand that out to you as
well but basically there was a a line
let me let me just hand I can hand that
out to you
I don't does everybody have one I think
everybody has the the First Amendment so
just tell us which okay line was struck
sure this the line that was struck was
the last sentence of
um Roman numeral two
it's on line 17 to 21 actually it's
lines 20 to 21 which says such grants
shall only be given to those
organizations with which have been in
existence for three years prior to the
date of the Grant application so my new
Amendment strikes that out because if a
County Government
is
um
seeking to essentially get seed money to
help in the operations of a new tourism
development program that program's not
been in existence for three years so
um I in my new amendment I struck that
okay thank you for the clarification
representative Brown you have a question
thank you Mr chairman so the uh
Amendment
2023-0238h that's the bill in its
entirety now yes sir thank you
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative for taking my question
how does this change the responsibility
right now the county just has uh
Department of Correction and Senior Care
are the two main uh focus and uh so this
would add to their portfolio of
responsibilities how would that change
the whole dynamics of County
well I guess if a county wants to
um
allocate some resources to
have people in their departments
maybe in the manager's department or you
know some of the other departments that
they have if they want to establish
some folks to work on County tourism
they can do that I suppose
but in the example we have in Sullivan
County
we had some people who volunteered their
time
to uh and they they actually we we
obtained a grant uh I don't remember
from where but uh we we obtained a grant
to do some work on uh tourism
development and it was called The Sugar
River destination Council which I served
on I still serve on and what we did was
the council decided it would be a better
thing to form a
501c3 or 501c4 organization
to continue doing the work that the
county had begun work on
so
it's possible that the county couldn't
initiate travel tourism development and
then help establish another organization
within the county that would
work
with businesses and with tourism Opera
you know tourist operators and so forth
to
um
to actually promote and manage and
I mean it's a great idea in terms of
diversification but my concern or have
you considered the fact that currently
counties are experiencing acute shortage
of Workforce to deliver services that
they have
how would this impact the operations of
a county I can you know uh would you uh
have you considered that in terms of the
impact on the functioning of the
counties as it exists well nobody would
be forcing counties to do this kind of
work I think it's if the Commissioners
in the county decide that this is
something that is worthwhile to bring
more tourism to their County they may
um so looking at the amendment uh it
says Grant applications
shall be reviewed by appropriate staff
which I'll recommend approval or
disapproval of applications to the
commissioner of Bea um so I'm wondering
would that be would they make new hires
for this or would this be an additional
responsibility for existing staff this
is this
this amendment is modeled exactly after
how they run their how Bea runs their
joint promotional program
so they would just be doing an expansion
and uh called the Operational Support
Program
which is modeled the same it would
operate the same way as jpp does but the
funds would be for
operations of of a tourism development
function that the county may have
or which a non-profit under the auspices
of the county may have so it just allows
for
funds to be used by the county which
county the county doesn't have any means
right now to access any months any grant
money through Bea so this just gives
representative lasalles
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question I'm just curious
normally when I think of
tourism and advertising for tourism I
think of States doing this
and I'm just wondering how the you don't
normally think of
like an ad running come to Sullivan
County you know
you do see ads for the states and I'm
just wondering how this would fit in
with the overall State of New Hampshire
strategy in encouraging tourists that's
a great question because what Bea even
told us was that their thrust is
bringing tourism to New Hampshire in
general
um so there really is no mechanism
whereby the counties can participate and
and and do marketing and development
work to bring people specifically to a
particular County
so this this helps the counties if they
want to
um do some sort of expansion of their
tourism
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I I think this is a
great idea I hope this is a great idea
I'm just looking in section two I just
want to see if I fully understand I
understand the appropriation of 750 000
to be made out of the out of the current
fiscal year and then everything else
goes into effect but about the lapsing
portion in in 2025 I'm not sure I
understand
that the the lapsing portion of that can
you explain that to me that's how the
funds are done through
um the regular jpp and again this was
modeled by uh
through okay the same it's the same kind
of way they they appropriate money it's
a biennium
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative so
when I look at this I'm I'm my I'm
thinking
do you have any idea as to what the
return on investment is with such a
program and have you looked to any other
states that have implemented a similar
program and um
to get a sense as to how successful
something like this would be I don't
know that would be a good question for
Bea to answer because I don't know what
their return on investment is for their
uh their promotional dollars so I I
for the questions
seeing that I have a couple
representative
um kind of following up on what
representative Gallagher spoke to and I
I understand this is modeled after
existing language but
um when I look at line 25 where it talks
about appropriate staff to me that's a
little bit on the
vague side as well as on lines 12 and 16
pretty much any time where they just
mention organizations it seems overly
broad I don't know if there would be
ways to make it more specific if we were
to move forward with this or not
um which lines I'm sorry uh 25 line 25
and like I say I do understand it's been
modeled after existing language but to
me that's just a little bit
I think what that is talking about is a
grant applications shall be reviewed by
appropriate staff from Bea
understood which shall recommend
approval or disapproval of applications
to the commissioner of Bea so they're
just saying how they're going to manage
managing this program
understood but you get my drift that I
think some of the
some of the wording might
possibly be a little better maybe I'm
wrong
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative okay appreciate it I do
not have any other pink cards does that
seeing none we'll close the hearing on
HB 489 and as I said at the beginning
uh the blue sheet has
we have 10 minutes before our next
scheduled meeting I think this is a
first where we're actually finished
early
um
we need to have a discussion
two discussions one for Democrats it's
going to be the exact same discussion
but I don't want to have it in open
public session so could I ask
um the
Democrats right now in the in the
gallery to vacate the room for a few
minutes please until 10 30 and then we
will have this same discussion with you
representative Aaron you're going to
have to vacate the room for us please
okay good afternoon or morning once
again everybody uh welcome we are about
to open up the hearing on
hb202 relative to property tax
abatements uh we have quite a few pink
cards we're going to give the sponsor as
much time as he needs to thoroughly
explain
for anybody else testifying we're going
to try to limit your speaking please to
about three minutes when Vice chairman
power holds us up that means you've
getting really close to your
three-minute limit if we can keep the
testimony
non-repetitive that would be great and
with that representative chinigian did I
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
for the record my name is representative
John janigian I represent Rockingham
District 25 which is Salem
I'm here to introduce HB 202
which is a bill relative to property tax
abatements
um last session HB 411 was passed and it
created a commission to study
this issue and the equalization rate
used for the calculation of property tax
abatements by the New Hampshire Board of
tax and land appeals and the superior
court and all cities towns and counties
the commission met in the summer of last
year came up with a wording that you see
on HB 202
that you have before you
I volunteered to put this bill in but
the experts testifying after me I think
can give a much better idea of of the um
the why of this wording and then I just
want to point out that if you look at
the last line
where it says
the the proposed change of full
reassessment to re
um oh wait a minute
where it says municipal
conducts a full reassessment at the end
there that the words full reassessment
um there's a proposed change
um to revaluation there and um
the ASB the assessing Standards Board
most recently met and decided that
change was appropriate
I can submit an amendment or I can talk
to one of you about that so simple
two-word change to one word full
reassessment to revaluation
that's all I have
um
and I think the experts testifying after
me can probably answer your questions
okay I'm going to take you at your word
on that are there any
I have a Jim wheeler
representing ASB
thank you very much uh representative
Brown
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so
um
the gist of it for you is that you want
it to be simplified so that
so that uh at the time the tax bill is
sent out that's the rate that's going to
be set correct
okay
follow up Mr chairman follow up
so the issue between the initial tax
bill and the next tax bill
is the concern that the rate changes
higher or lower or just that it simply
changes during that process so there's a
legal issue with that
there we go so it the issue occurs it's
a
a one-way issue if you will when
when the property Market is rising
the equalization rates typically will
drop
and in those instances uh
you will see and we see as a firm
municipality see it there's a myriad of
abatement requests that occur that are
people call them it's a Equalization
rate abatement request for no other
reason other than they're taking
advantage of the fact that the
equalization rate is going down now
conversely if you expand the frame
when the property Market is going down
and Equalization rates are going up and
that does occur in fact it happened the
year before this Burling case
you know if if everything were Equitable
then the taxpayer would come forth and
pay a higher Bill to their municipality
that never happens
um
in the Berlin case I think it was you
know would have been upwards of uh 200
um
that had the taxpayer had to make an
adjustment because the equalization rate
was going up you know they would pay but
that doesn't happen so the the point of
the bill is just to
make the system more Equitable so the
rate that's in effect when the bills go
out would be the rate that's applied
when there's an appeal
representative status
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm so glad you're
here because this is so complicated
um and I apologize in advance if this is
a simple-minded question
in the Supreme Court case that you
mentioned
is it in fact true that this legislative
language that you are proposing if
passed would be contrary to what the
um I don't view it that way no
no
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question on line six could you
define
um I don't actually have the
bill in front of me but I mean the
median ratio I can say and I'm not an
assessor and not an appraiser but median
ratio is one of the statistics that is
determined by the dra there are you know
other ratios but the median ratio is the
ratio that is used for the equalization
rate
and there are assessors who are behind
me that can just do a much better job at
describing that oh okay you want to wait
uh representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um just representative genegian referred
to this and I just want to make sure I'm
clear I did have uh concern about the
term a full reassessment do I can do you
also agree that that could be changed to
reval or revaluation rather than
reassessment for those towns that do not
do a full reval full measuring list we
do a statistical update yes I do okay
yeah thank you thank you representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
when you talk about the reassessment
only when there is a challenge for
abatement to look at the reassessment of
the property so this applies across
single family to commercial to any
property in the municipality
thank you
while you're up there just keep your the
microphone on so when you answer yeah
oh I have to I just yeah there we go
further questions
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um how would this work with the let's
see
the bill we passed last year I think or
at least in the last session 76 15 a a
the quarterly billing of taxes uh
certain towns and cities has to do with
if there's a big jump in revenues
because of a case in Northwood I think
would this
is this very separate and I mean can we
read it as very separate because it's a
different section
oh it's not really
I
I would again probably defer to uh some
of the other folks that will speak but I
believe that
um and I'm not familiar with that bill
but that
um
the abatement process isn't Changed by
the bill last year so I think if that's
the case then it wouldn't have any
effect
representative power you had another
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking a second question
I understand you don't have the bill
language in front of you but
this bill deals with market value
throughout
and on lines three and four
um particular statutes are referenced
RSA
7616 76 16a and 76.
17.
and when I reference those and looked
back there was no reference to market
value is that implied with regard to if
an abatement is granted there just seem
to be some type of a disconnect for me
well I think the the term market value
was there simply because that is the
goal of assessment
um is to determine the market value of
any property when you know for taxation
purposes and
um
again without
there are folks who can speak better to
it but it's it's a it's a
you know when you reval when a community
conducts a revaluation uh typically once
every five years the goal is to bring
are there any more questions for Mr
Wheeler
seeing none I have a couple for you
really quickly uh you talked about the
equalization abatement request how many
um I mean every municipality is
different are you asking specifically
for uh what how many a municipality may
see
whatever ones that you may be personally
familiar with well in my current work we
see many because we're a firm that does
appraisals for multiple municipalities
let me give you this this would be a
probably a good data point I'm currently
aware of two small towns that we serve
two small North Country towns that both
both towns have on the order of
ten to a dozen
abatement requests that are solely based
on this Equalization issue
okay
um
I are the abatement Equalization
abatement or quests are they primarily
residential or commercial or is there a
mix or what's the ratio you commercial
the ones that I just spoke about in
these small towns are commercial
um by large commercial but also you also
see them in the utility sector obviously
a lot of dollars at stake
uh when it's a multi-million dollar
utility you know whether it's a power
plant or or otherwise so is it would it
be fair to say it's very few residential
I think so I think that's probably a
fair statement
okay thank you very much representative
yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
is it your understanding that that
um that any taxpayer would be able to
take advantage of this uh abatement
process and and
um so it's not disproportionately
affecting
um uh commercial they're just the ones
that are more likely to uh uh go through
the process or is or is it special to
them that they have some special
category
I I suppose any taxpayer could take
advantage of it
um
again
the taking advantages only when the
market is decreasing and there's no
adjustment when the I mean when the
market is increasing but there's no
adjustment when the property Market is
decreasing
okay so you know more questions thank
you very much for your testimony thank
also remind everybody when you first
speak not only your name but if you're
microphone
thank you my name is uh Patrick Bigg I'm
opposed to this bill
I represent a commercial product tax
management I'm a tax consulting firm
uh in Manchester New Hampshire
we represent
many clients both residential and
commercial in the tax abatement process
the purpose of the tax abatement is to
have an Avenue in which the taxpayer can
challenge that assessment
right on
the form 7616 it explains you take the
assessment to come up with market value
and divide it by the ratio
the ratio is a
measure of portionality amongst
properties
if an abatement is granted
I don't understand why
the previous year's ratio would be used
it would in a down Market
um if the assessments are actually in an
upmarket if the assessments are dropping
um the ratios are dropping
um the
um
proportionality of that particular
property each abatement is have the
burden of proof is on the taxpayer
so
um
in this bill as it's written it's
assuming that a hundred percent on a
revaluation so you ignore
the dras methodology for proportionality
to come up
with a an abatement based on a hundred
percent
and it would ignore year five in the
year five year rebound cycle because
whatever ratio they came up with there
they would use the previous year's ratio
to calculate an abatement
some of these ratios are changing at a
dramatic rate in this market it's not a
de minimis amount of money we're talking
about if for example you have an
assessment of 10 million dollars
and in Sunapee this year's ratio dropped
20 percent
if you have a commercial property or a
residential property for that matter at
a 10 million dollar market value that's
two million dollars in assessment and a
two percent rate
that's you know 10 to 20 percent can can
mean
um you know ten to twenty thousand
dollars or more
in
in over in under abating
the amount of money that's owed to a
taxpayer that has met the burden of
proof
with the assessor so
the other thing I'd like to point out is
when an abatement is filed as of March 1
of each year
the town has until July 1 to respond to
that appeal at that point the ratio is
already determined they know what it is
Moses most assessors know what their
ratio is going to be
along the way
even at the time they issue the bill in
December
so
they have a pretty good idea of what
their what they're assessing in in where
their uh information is uh leading them
so I think that
um this would be harmful to the taxpayer
um in disproportionate
um
if the market goes the other way and
Market values start
declining you could have in a situation
where a ratio is a hundred and ten
hundred and twenty percent where you
could be over abating
money so I think the question is not
using the previous year's ratio but
maybe figuring out a way to come up with
the ratio prior to the bills going out
thank you
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question yeah can you explain to me
like I'm in grammar school okay
everything you just said I'm sorry
and and what the stakes are here I I get
lost between Equalization and ratio and
just pretend I'm 10 years old so
so the the ratio is established by the
dra based on the statistical information
that's applied
to from the town to the state
they get a ratio for that year
the problem is at the time of filing the
um but by the time you go through the
abatement process that ratio is
established
and
right on the appeal form under RNC 7616
it states that to determine your your
assessment you take them
or market value take your
your assessment and divide it by the
ratio and that tells you what the town
is saying your market value is
and if you the burden of proof is on the
taxpay if they feel that it's over
assessed they file an appeal go through
the process an abatement is granted
they have to apply that ratio to the new
number and calculate the abatement why I
don't understand why you would use the
previous year's market value ratio that
the state in the towns have the ability
to appeal 30 days within 30 days of the
I'm sorry if it
yeah
representative bro
okay so just a quick clarification I
think the two people are testifying to
testifying from two different
perspectives so can you clarify at this
point that my issue would be okay I'm
taxed at a certain rate each year yep
okay is the issue that okay
representative Brown could you pull that
mic closer too sure sorry so is the
issue that
at the time the tax bills come out I'm
at one rate and then by the time you do
the abatement you've got a different
rate is it a question of being
this is the time that I'm doing it and
later on the value might have gone down
and I'm paying more than I should have I
mean that ratio could change right where
you could say oh now I've got to pay
more is that not correct no
um it's based on market value and there
the assessors are uh determining Market
values of April one of each year that's
the snapshot in time that they're
assessing all properties
okay in this and they they do a
statistical
update or or report the ms1 report to
the Department of Revenue and the
Department of Revenue will say your
ratio to Mark you know assessment to
Market is this and it's applied to all
properties equally for
for determining market value
so I so what I'm saying is why would you
use the previous year's market value
ratio to determine an abatement that's
granted based on the the numbers that
the state
quick follow-up
so
you're just saying do you want to use
the current Year's ratio as opposed to a
previous ratio correct so it's this
correct ratio just more accurate the
correct ratio that the state
uh sets with the municipality that seems
pretty straightforward thank you
so we do see more questions here's what
I'm going to also suggest at the end
only I'm going to suggest it now for
those of you who are for this bill
get together and those who are against
this bill get together and draw us up
some very simplistic scenarios an actual
case scenario that you can present to us
so we can understand a little better
what what you're saying in other words
don't don't use a figure like one
million two hundred and eighty nine
thousand dollars say one million you
know just make it a very simple case
that you can give to us so we really
have a good understanding of what you're
trying to do represent a man to Puti
thank you Mr chair thank you for for
taking my questions
how would this impact different
communities high density with more
commercial and residential mixed versus
rural very sparsely
populated would it have a very different
impact based on the density of
properties
I I in my expert opinion I would say
that
municipalities with commercial
properties would be in a in in
increasing market value would have more
that's
ratios don't deter aren't stratified
based on class of property in I would
say over 90 percent of the sales that
are analyzed by the dra to the for from
the municipality are residential in
nature so if you have an increasing
market value of Residential Properties
the ratio is going to Free Fall
um and it's gonna over assess
on market value when applying that ratio
commercially
because they're not increasing at the
same rate that
um residential are
so I in it
in a
ink that's an increasing market value
residentially if if it's declining then
it's going to benefit the commercial
um
properties
so you know further questions thank you
very much for your testimony we'll call
yes representative Guthrie yeah if I
could Mr chairman just to get my head
straight is it my understanding there is
going to be a Amendment
the sponsor said that there would be an
amendment coming forward
it would there would be an amendment
just changing two words
thank you Mr chairman sure
thank you Robert gagne I'm here as the
vice chair of the assessing Standards
Board the chair Betsy Patton couldn't be
here and she asked me to be here to
report on the board's vote as Mr Willis
stated at our meeting of January 6th I
believe we went over this issue and we
voted as the assessing Standards Board
to be supportive of this bill with a
change in that those two words full
reassessment to revaluation so the board
is in favor
um
but it might be helpful to have an
explanation as to why this was taken up
in the first place
I think Mr Biggs said that you know we
we
use the same ratio to assess all
properties and we don't
um there are certain properties that we
have to assess
by the time we submit our ms-1
that we have to use the prior Year's
ratio for because we don't know the
current Year's ratio and those property
values are based on on that adjustment
they include utility properties that we
that we have to reassess every year
whether we're doing a general
revaluation or not they include current
use properties and they include any
low-income housing tax credit properties
that have signed up to be treated under
RSA 751a where we have to calculate
those values every year so we have to
apply a ratio to get their market value
to the same general level of assessment
as the rest of the city or town the
ratio we know about is the prior Year's
ratio what happens is we'll set that
value send out a tax bill and then if
the ratio drops
for example a utility property even
though we set the value per statute
would benefit from a dropping ratio and
would come in and seek an abatement with
the ratio that was unknown when we set
their value
now I believe the commission examined
more than one way to address this
problem and this ended up being in my
opinion these least disruptive as far as
all the other processes that the state
goes through
the issue is that the Department of
Revenue
establishes an equalization ratio to
determine the market value of every city
and town in the state every year
and it's based on an April 1st date
and they use a sales period of six
months before and after April 1st so
it's October 1st of the prior year
through September 30th of the current
year is that study period
because of that
and and the ms-1 needs to be submitted
by September 1st we don't know what the
current Year's ratio is
um the state so one of the solutions
would have been hey change that period
of time so that you know the current
Year's ratio
when you set the tax rate and send out
the tax bills have that period be the 12
months leading up to April 1st
the problem with that is that it it
disrupts the the primary task the
Department of Revenue has to do and I
believe they have a representative here
and he can probably address this
um
right now because you're using six
months before and after April 1st you
don't have to time Trend the sales to
get to the right number if it's an
increasing or decreasing Market you have
you know some sales before and after and
it it evens out for the most part
um in an increasing Market if you set
the ratio into 12 months before
it's going to fall short of that
Equalization number they're seeking
the Department's Equalization process is
primarily for that
equalizing cities and towns for purposes
of the county tax and school aid and so
forth the median ratio and the other
statistics they generate is are our
byproduct it's not their primary goal to
set those
so they provide them as part part of the
process but there's a mismatch between
the equalization process and the
abatement process
again there would have been other
solutions to this like changing that
time frame but that would have been very
disruptive to what the dra does I can
tell you that from an assessing
standpoint from the assessor for the
city of Manchester I was skeptical about
this change for some of the same reasons
that Mr Big indicated that you know by
the time we process the abatements we
know what the ratio is
but after listening to and talking with
the members of the commission and and
seeing what they had to deal with to get
to this point
um
I think this is a reasonable solution
um you know this this way those
properties for which we have to use the
prior years ratio to send out the tax
bill you know utilities current use
low-income housing tax credit properties
um
using with this statute we'd be applying
the same ratio to all of the other
properties in a municipality so and it
and it and I also want to make clear
something that was said that may not
have been said
loudly enough
this can work both ways in a declining
Market
the ratio is going to be over 1
the city or town can't go back and Bill
those properties that underpaid for the
last year because per Supreme Court
decision in Pheasant Lane Mall once we
send out a tax bill we can't recoup if
if the value was wrong
that's case law so in those cases as Mr
Wheeler indicated when the Market's
decreasing this works in favor of those
properties utilities commercial
properties it works against a
municipality
in in that decreasing Market where the
ratio should get us more tax revenue
from those properties and it doesn't
so I think this is the least disruptive
and and the cleanest
representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
are are you
saying that when a tax bill goes out
that the bill is not based on the
current years for for at least some of
them you you exam gave examples of of uh
some situations where you're doing the
prior year assessment but is it
isn't it the case that they that the
final tax bill in usually in December
for at least my town
is using the actual
um rate set by the dra for the Abate for
the um the ratio for that current year
correct so it's it's the tax rate based
on the assessed value
now if every property
changed in value at the same rate
we wouldn't be having this conversation
the issue occurs so in the year of the
reval we're all at market value or
that's the target
so so that tax rate is applied to that
as time goes on
resident when the Market's increasing
rapidly it's really as Mr Big said it's
you know 90 percent of the of the
activity is Residential Properties going
up commercial properties don't change at
the same rate for a lot of reasons
um
you know generally commercial property
that's investment it's tied to a lease
that's more than a year you can't raise
your rates on that like you can on a
residential property whether it's an
apartment or not so values diverge as
you go along
um I'll give you an example
um
in the year of the reval in Manchester
last
2021 our ratio is 96.1 percent
in a year of revalue is supposed to be
between 90 and 110 so we will find I
just yesterday got I probably shouldn't
say this in front of Mr big but I will
anyways
um we just got our ratio yesterday and
again it's a 30-day period to challenge
it but we're at 82.2 percent so we went
from 96 to 82.2 in a year that's an
indication that the market increased
roughly 15 16 in a year
it's all driven by residential sales
Commerce you know single-family condo
small multis two to four family
commercial properties
with a few exceptions commercial
properties didn't change at that rate so
that tax rate that we're applying to the
assessment may be unequal as you go away
from the revalue year and the abatement
process is how we take care of that
right you apply for local abatement
it's market value times the ratio this
is just determining which ratio it is
and there was a question about
um
about 76 16
in 16a and 17 not talking about market
value I'm looking at the language on
line three and four of the proposal
and what it says is if an abatement is
granted
with a determination of market value so
I'm skipping the quote so it doesn't
need market value doesn't need to be
quoted in 76 16a or 17 it's addressed
here if the abatement that's being
granted
is because of the market value you're
going to apply that ratio so so we do
apply that ratio this is just a matter
which ratio we're going to apply
again you know I was skeptical about
this initially it's a tough problem uh
and and you know as was stated we kind
of know where our ratio is going to be
if we are close to our sales and have
been working with those unfortunately we
don't have that official ratio when the
tax rate is set and when the bills go
out
so it's a problem
further questions representative
majority
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for taking
my question
um I bet when I asked this question I
realized how little I know even though
I've been doing this for a little while
um does this have any effect on the
coefficient of dispersion or because I
do look at that when when we get that
number I'm just curious if it affects
that ratio in such a way that the town
the Cod doesn't the coefficient of
dispersion doesn't come into play as far
as the abatement process
it might be an indication when that gets
too high that you need to do something
that that you know your your
um your data is not good or whatever so
it's another indicator of the quality of
your values
um
but I I don't think it would have an
impact on on what this legislation is
so like my question is is the issue
um
related to the fact that the commercial
rate ratio is should possibly be
different than the residential ratio to
address this as opposed to that way it's
you're going to hear you could hear a
lot of opinions about that there's been
arguments about that
um over time that you know it the
commercial property shouldn't shouldn't
um
take advantage of a dropping ratio
here's the thing State of New Hampshire
we all pay
property taxes based on
a general level of assessment market
value doesn't matter if it's a single
family The Mall of New Hampshire they're
only required to pay their fair share
and so long as we're all paying the same
tax rate meaning we don't have a split
rate where commercial properties pay a
different rate like Massachusetts has
that where you can have a different rate
for residential versus commercial in
that case I would say you ought to be
using a ratio for each
where it's one tax rate here uh I think
to be fair in my definition of fair is
it doesn't matter who the taxpayer is
we're only required to pay our share
um then I I think we we need to use the
single rate and we shouldn't have a rate
different rate for for residential the
solution would be to do a rebal every
year it's just that's expensive that's
my next question that's expensive it's
not required by law it's not required by
uh by the Constitution it's it's every
representative yakella
thank you uh thank you for taking the
question
so
I'm just trying to understand
why we would consider the previous year
if if we're if
you were assessed
uh you are reevaluated and occurring in
in the year 2000 you
um
file for an abatement because you
believe that is incorrect in the year
2000 for the tax bill that's in 2000
why would you be cons why is it proper
to be considering year 1999
for the
for that new assessment
uh valuation
um
because isn't the the
the new assessed value based off of that
new uh ratio
thank you that's a good question because
per this proposal
in that year the revaluation 2000 if you
set new values we would be we would
assume you're at a hundred percent
so the ratio would be a hundred it would
be it would be the current ratio in the
year of the revaluation
it's what happens as you move away from
that year
that that's a concern that this seeks to
address that in that second year
now you're not necessarily applying the
tax rate to
the same market value for everybody
right so if residential is increasing
faster than commercial
you know that ratio is going to indicate
that
um
it's complicated it's complicated for
somebody who's been in it for 20 years
so
again you know your point about using
if we could like split off those utility
properties and current use properties on
low-income housing tax credit properties
from consideration meaning okay
because we had to use last year's ratio
to tack those that's the ratio that they
have to use for the abatement process
going forward
I would be fine with using the current
ratio for the new abatements because
that's the level of assessment
the issue is follow-up
am I incorrect that says that that I was
saying that you would be using based on
this language that you would be using
1999 because you seem to be saying that
you would be using the hundred percent
for this year but in the language it
says you would be using
the prior year so you don't am I
confused yeah so you don't use the prior
year in a year of reevaluation that's
um so the last sentence line seven and
eight the market value of the property
shall be equalized at a hundred percent
in any tax year for which the
municipality conducts a revaluation if
you amend that in accordance with RSA 75
1 and 75 8A so in that example if if
2000 was the year of the reval
you would use a hundred percent you
okay
seeing no more we do need to move on
we're getting extremely behind thank you
representative you Keller representative
vehicle
Mr snow good morning my name is Chris
snow
I'm the president of property tax
advisors we are a taxpayer
Representatives
been in business here in New Hampshire
for just about 30 years now representing
taxpayers
so I understand there's a lot of
confusion about
rates and ratios and
that assessments and and taxes
um one one easy way to explain I think
the ratio is that when a municipality
does a revaluation they typically here
in New Hampshire do it every five years
although there are some municipalities
that choose to do it more frequently
some annually
but when they do the revaluation the
goal is to get all the assessed values
to Market
so they'll adjust each value depending
on the actions of the market because
every property changes in value in
different ways it's not simply
residential versus commercial there's
lots of segments in a market
there's vacant land there's Condominiums
there's mobile homes there's
single-family homes and then on the
commercial side there's a a whole
variety of properties as well they all
move it at different
rates over the years and that's why they
have a revaluation but when they do the
revaluation it's at a hundred percent
and what happens is is that in this
current market as the as as the market
values go up the ratio as a percentage
of market value goes down so if the
market value goes up by 10 in a year
then the ratio will be approximately 90
percent and then if it goes up another
10 percent the next year then the ratio
Falls to you know approximately a little
over 80 percent so
um so that's the relationship between
that assessed value and the market value
and whenever you can test an assessment
here in New Hampshire the the ratio is
an integral part of any tax appeal it's
it's how the
State determines proportionality a lot
of people think proportionality is
another term that people misunderstand a
lot a lot of people think it has to do
with similar properties in town and you
want to be assessed in a similar fashion
but it really has to do with
proportionality is the relationship of
of you the market value to the assessed
value considering the ratio so you need
all three of those components and any
successful tax appeal
and it's not necessarily to one side's
advantage or the other it just depends
on the market and in this current market
which is unprecedented in my in my
experience
we've had values going up dramatically
for Residential Properties and some
commercial properties as well but
largely Residential Properties are
leading the charge
and it seems to me that this bill the
way it's written would just introduce an
inequity into the system and I think it
would probably benefit the
municipalities in an up Market but I
think that should the market start to go
down which it will when I first got into
this business a lot of the ratios were
over 100 percent 110 120 130 140 percent
as showing that the assessed value as it
related to the market value the assessed
value was quite a bit higher than the
market value so very different from
today and I think in a market like that
you know this type of legislation could
benefit
the uh the taxpayer so I think I think
there could be some unintended
consequences here uh with this proposed
legislation
but that the benefit of the abatement
process is that it's retroactive the the
municipality is looking back on the
previous year so the municipality is
able to kind of like the instant replay
in in a football game or something they
can look it over again and and take a
look at the whole market and they have
all the information in front of them
looking back including the ratio
um I will say it is a challenge for
taxpayers when they're filing for
abatement because the Department of
Revenue Administration doesn't publish
their ratio until after abatement
applications are due and that is a
problem for taxpayers because they're
they're kind of in the dark as to what
the ratio is
but as uh
as the assessor for Manchester Mr gagne
just testified they know the ratio right
now you know down to a tenth of a
percentage point I mean they know
exactly what their ratio is and
abatement applications aren't due until
March 1st so
to me I think it's more of an issue of
transparency that the Department of
Revenue Administration if there's any
way that they could get their ratio out
a little sooner if the municipalities
would would provide this information to
the taxpayers there's a lot of taxpayers
in New Hampshire that don't even know
what the ratio is they don't even know
that there is a ratio they assume that
the assessed value that they have is the
municipalities estimate of the fair
market value
so I think I don't think it's so much of
a loophole that we're talking about here
I think it's just a fairness issue and I
hate the basis legislation on what I
consider to be
atypical properties like utilities and
current use I mean those are two wildly
at the other end of the spectrum
properties one current use being
assessed for so low uh based on uh
legislation and utilities so high
because they have that value so I don't
think it would be fair to to have
legislation based on these these type of
extremes
thank you for allowing me to testify
thank you do we have any questions
I have one
um
your company property tax advisors uh
could you give me approximate
ratio of the work that you do
three quarters of our work is is
commercial and one quarter is
residential
we really uh the abatement is set up to
for the purpose of properties that are
out of step with the market so when we
file for an abatement it tends to be on
properties that aren't in step with the
ratio and that can be residential or
commercial but to answer your question
totally understood okay any other
questions representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
when
it so there is a requirement that every
five years the entire
municipality is is essentially
reassessed
um
in my municipality they are doing a
does the um does the re-evaluation
um
language that is being proposed because
it's not no longer full reassessment
it's now considered re-evaluation how
does that
um in your opinion factor into
uh
municipalities that do this constant
reevaluation versus a single uh
five-year
reassessment I'm not an assessor but in
observing the way municipalities behave
certain municipalities will
just do a complete revaluation every
five years others have a kind of a
rolling approach that you mentioned
others have these statistical updates
which
appears to be a revaluation but might
not involve a complete measure in list
so I think there's a variety of
approaches that the municipalities use
so I don't know how I think that would
just further confuse the language of the
uh of the pro of the bill but uh
um I don't know specifically how that
would affect your town
so you know more questions thank you for
your testimony we have one last pink
thank you for the opportunity to testify
my name is Scott Barlett I am the
assessor of the town of Goffstown I was
on the equalization commission I was
appointed by the governor I do have
written testimony
um would you like me to just leave that
up here just leave it on that other pile
we'll distribute it afterwards thank you
okay I won't go over everything I'll try
to be brief
a couple points I want to make as an
assessors it is my job to assess
property as of April 1st and what is
known as of April 1st
as of April 1st I know
the previous year's Equalization study
uh so if I was talking last year 2022 so
the 2021 Equalization study would have
used sales from
October 1st
to September 30th
and that is usually released sometime in
January or February so at the time that
I am assessing property which is April
1st that is what is known
okay now do I know that other sales have
occurred yes I do
but typically when I'm doing my analysis
and I'm looking forward to set my values
I'm not considering what happens after
April 1st the ratio study that will come
out
prior after that subsequent to that for
2022 use a six months of sales after
April 1st those are not known as of
April 1st
I do not consider the dras ratio study
to be the best way to determine what I
consider to be the level of assessment
as available first
it is what we have now on the commission
we did discuss a lot of different
approaches and I'll be honest with you
this is not the best approach it is the
most practical approach
the best approach would be to use what
is considered a time-adjusted ratio
study using six or using 12 months of
sales prior to April 1st as an assessor
I do that and just to give you an
example of of how ratios change my ratio
in 2021 was 70 percent
I did a trended Time trended approach to
determine what I considered to be my
ratio as of April 1st of 2022 I came out
at 68 percent
I just received my dra
um
Equalization survey by median ratio is
63 so I have three different ratios
there
if we use the best approach we I would
be using 68 but again is that practical
no
you know I have the expertise to be able
to do that I have the resources to be
able to do that but I'll be honest with
you most municipalities do not
and that is the problem
um
so it really comes down to fairness
the vast majority of properties are
being valued based on what we know as of
April 1st
when someone files an abatement they're
getting
the benefit of hindsight
and that I do not believe that is the
intent I do not believe that is
Equitable I just would like to refer to
a couple comments or a couple of
statements that were made in the Supreme
Court decision
um
disproportionality and not methodology
is the linchpin and establishing
entitlement to a petition for abatement
end quote essentially what this saying
is using a ratio for appeal properties
is different than the known ratio
is not is just disproportionate
uh one more quote from the Supreme Court
decision
um begin quote we note that the dra's
equalization studies do not precisely
coincide with any particular tax year
a tax year runs from April 1st to March
31st
however the dra's equalization studies
run from October 1st to December 30th
therefore no dra Equalization ratio is
based on every single sale sorry on
every sale occurring during the 12
months immediately proceeding April 1st
so again
emphasizing my point sales that occur
Apple after April 1st are not known and
should not be part of a
ratio that is used for abatement
purposes I do have more comments that
are in my written testimony I will stop
there and I would enter entertain any
questions
thank you very much representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
is this legislation an attempt to fix a
deficit on the part of the dra
is that what we're looking at here that
they're the the ratios are not accurate
or in some way adequate and this
legislation is attempt to kind of
shoehorn a solution around that problem
okay thank you for the question
um no it is not uh one of the points
that that Mr gagne was making is that
the primary purpose of the equalization
study is not to equalize between
individual properties its primary
purpose is to equalize between
communities between municipalities it
works extremely well for that
it doesn't work extremely well for
equalizing between properties within a
town
representative manager Puti
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so if I understand
um do you believe that the equalization
is a lagging dra's Equalization ratio is
lagging behind uh
the wave if you're setting as an
assessor at April 1st so you're
reflecting on the back
rear view mirror to get that so and
also this is like you just said a couple
or apples to oranges
uh thank you for the question
um
again when you look at the primary
purpose of the equalization survey no it
is not lagging
but when you start looking at the
Assessor's duties
is it the perfect solution
for using for equalizing between
properties no it is not
but it is what we have one of the
problems we have
with our current system is that we have
a five-year cycle and we are required to
revalue properties every five years
but the abatement process essentially
creates a one-year cycle
and it creates a a cycle of hindsight
which again to me as an assessor I
for other taxpayers those who don't file
thank you
um I don't believe you said at the
beginning but I'm assuming you're in
favor of this bill oh I'm sorry I
apologize yes I am in favor of this one
last question quickly representative
yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
am I correct uh
when I'm looking at this this language
based on my previous question of a of a
previous uh speaker
um
it seemed to be that that the first
sentence of how we're going to
determinate determine someone's
um
uh
ratio is is
uh the previous year
in situations where it's not a full
reassessment year and then a hundred
percent for years that it is a
reassessment year is that your
understanding of how this should be
interpreted
um
were you referring to your previous
question uh thank you for the question
but were you referring to your previous
question about how your town does
one-fifth a year
no no okay I mean so
clarify yeah
um
so
the um the language here says that
um market value of the property for a
given year shall be equalized by
multiplying the market value of the
property by the previous tax year
so that's one situation of what you're
supposed to do and then in the second
sentence it says something else do
something else and so my
my question is
is it an if
um if you're doing this then do this
ratio if you're doing that do this other
ratio or do this other math equation
okay thank you yes now I understand the
question
um yes it is an if
um so essentially in my town in
Goffstown I am doing a revaluation this
year I'm doing value Anew in 2023. so
when I am dealing with 2023 abatements
by this law I would use 100 percent
in all other years when I am not doing a
revaluation I would be looking at the
previous years
okay
thank you for your testimony I don't
have any more pink cards for this bill
on the blue sign-in sheet I have three
four and two against and with that we'll
open up the hearing on
hb203 relative to publication of annual
County budgets the sponsor has another
engagement and another committee
representative lasalles I believe you
you can stay right there representative
lasalles that's fine I'm sorry
no I'm sorry you're not hearing I
couldn't hear but there was voice record
2.6 we are on HP 203 we're a little
behind oh that's okay thank you so much
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
my name is Richard lucelis
I uh represent Hillsboro uh district 14
which is the town of Litchfield I'm here
to introduce uh HB 203
uh relative to the publication of annual
County budgets I'm introducing this uh
because representative Edwards the prime
sponsor is unable to be here at this
point
um the bill
makes some
minor changes to the way that uh
uh the county budgets for Hillsboro and
Rockingham are delivered and posted and
I'm going to ask Chuck Nickerson who is
the CFO of Rockingham County
uh to answer any questions that you
[Music]
next we like to call up to the podium
and if you could turn off your mic
good morning uh so basically this bill
just request to minor changes could you
please introduce us who you are and
whether you're foreign well Charles
Nickerson uh senior director of Finance
for Arkham County I'm for this bill
uh this bill basically makes two basic
changes basically Common Sense updates
to the existing RSA
um basically we are looking to kind of
bring into the 21st century as far as
instead of having copies of the
executive committee proposed budget to
the overall County Convention to be made
available at the county courthouse for
and said that to be posted online on the
respective County's websites I believe
currently that's already kind of the
process that's done by uh you know by
whoever's in charge of of monitoring the
county websites
um also we'd be looking to provide and
this will be coming forth in a in a
future amendment that representative
Edwards will be proposing to the
committee but
um what should be the language in the
bill is that basically that the the
budgets need to go out for the
Commissioners proposed by May 3rd
but May 10th should remain as the date
deadline date for the public hearing so
that will be a future proposed amendment
that representative Edwards will bring
forward to the committee
basically this will give one week
separation that the stakeholders are
receiving these proposed Commissioners
budgets have to look at it and to know
whether or not they should be in
attendance for that you know public
hearing on the commissioner's proposed
budget
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so I'm looking at the
text of the bill and on line 15
um
inserts or amends to to include the
words or delivered could you please
define the word delivered and what is
what's meant by that so it might mean
something different between Hillsboro OR
Rockin counties at at you know Rockham
County basically the the delivery is
actually two by mail to each and every
individual representative
so as far as Rockin County that's that's
how we've interpreted that we have the
budgets delivered by mail to each and
every uh state representative from
representative Yokel
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um from your testimony it seemed that
you would prefer that there be some time
before between delivery of the
um the uh budget and the hearing on the
budget however
um it says
um
that the the dates all say prior to so
couldn't that technically be they could
have a public hearing date on May 1st
and they could give you the budgets on
May 2nd and still be in compliance with
they it could I again the intent was to
technically provide some some difference
so whether maybe instead the future
Amendment says
yeah well again it's hard to say May
10th specify
you know a specific date because I could
fall on whatever day of the week so
the the intent was
again maybe the amendment will say no
earlier than or or again we're trying to
provide a a week's notice or a
difference to give individuals a chance
you know whether it's state reps or I
think we're trying to talk about
amendments that are not in front of us
which is very difficult and probably not
the best
use of the committee's time but yes the
the intent was not for it to be on the
on the same date that was an honest
mistake
for the questions representative
Manchester uh thank you Mr just a
clarification for the chair I noticed
that I keep my hand up and then I put it
down so uh do you want me to keep my
hand up so sometimes it feels like I
might have sh my question has been
answered so you don't recognize unless I
put my hand up again sure I tried to do
my best I know I know I'm just trying to
clarify how uh what I need to do yeah go
like that keep it like that okay thank
you Mom Mr chair thank you for taking my
question my question is why single out
Hillsborough County and Rockingham
County alone how would this impact other
counties
since this bill is it basically Hills
Rockingham County share a budget bill
that has specific rules that we have to
follow for our budgeting process and so
this would only affect Hillsborough and
Rockin County
um you know basically other sections of
whether it's RSA I think 2413 2414
representative stavis
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'd like to drill down a
little bit more on the word delivered if
I may
uh
everybody understands what mailed means
delivered is somewhat ambiguous
can you tell me what it means to deliver
again we've taken a different way I
guess you take delivery to to mean that
in whichever former way that the
recipient you know
truly actually receives delivery of the
the budget it would it be fair let me
just
go a little deeper into what
representative Davis is saying is it is
it your intention to kind of match up
what it says in Hillsborough the
paragraph above and the one below
because the one above says mail door
delivered is the reason you added the
word delivered in that bottom one to
make them
in sync is that what's happening here or
I think it's trying to get wording more
consistent with
representative Gallagher
um so
the part about the County website
um so yeah I think posting
it on the County website is a good idea
but my question is why have that
replacing the part where it says at the
county
Courthouse like why can't we say
they have to do it at both or they have
I think it's it's basically because
again there's Rock aims experience that
because we do the delivery
the mailing of whatever stage of the
budget that we're at as required to the
state representatives in the county uh
to their homes that
that basically that's not a needed
part of the RSA because they are
actually receiving in different method
individually to their homes uh the the
budgets and
by again up and operationally to my
knowledge no state representative from
rockhamp has gone to get their budget at
so basically trying to update the the
law to again bring us into the 21st
century and add it to the County's
website as far as for being part of the
again proposed law
represent power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so my understanding
is that you're a representative from
Rockingham County and this bill affects
both Hillsboro and Rockingham County my
question is do you have do you know if
anybody from Hillsborough County was
consulted with regards to the the
changes proposed in this legislation
in particular the um I'm referencing the
the strikeout in lines 17 and 18 with
regard to at the County Courthouse as
well as the the whole conversation
around the word delivered
so was Hillsboro
um consulted did they have any input
into this legislation yes so so
basically both counties and all 10
counties are part of the New Hampshire
Association of counties and so there's
representatives from uh from Hillsboro I
should say State represents but there's
there's
um members from Hillsborough County that
are part of the representation of the
executive committee of the of the nhac
and the build language was sent to them
to for them to reach back to their
I cannot say as far as how far it went
on on their side as far as bring back
any comments
okay so you know
hands uh thank you for your testimony we
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Kate Horgan I
represent the New Hampshire Association
of counties uh we do support the bill
um just to kind of cover quick little
questions the chair is 100 correct or
delivered on line 15 was put in to match
the language in line three uh I don't
know what the original definition of
delivered was but that was just a
technical cleanup that we thought it
should match the language in line three
um
on the uh
the date we did ask representative
Edwards about making that a little more
time period that way people have time to
review the budget especially the public
before they go to a public hearing it
just gives everyone some time to look
over it so that way they know whether or
not they feel it is important for them
as a member of the public to go and
testify to the um
on the budget
um I think that was all the questions
but if I miss something I am happy to
take a question
foreign
yes thank you for your testimony
um
would
elect uh the budget being
delivered electronically would that
suffice for the requirement
I am not sure when this bill was or this
language was put into statute I would
assume but I am also not a lawyer so I
don't know if you want to take my word
for that representative
but I'm happy to look into it and see if
I can figure it out for you
thank you
representative
um Mr Speaker isn't um since
representative lasalles uh introduced
the bill is he not it wasn't that a
violation of the current law or the
current rule you are correct okay you
are correct but but also I have a
um the
um
after my previous question about the the
um the time frame
um it looks like in the current law it
says that there needs to be at least
seven days prior to any vote
uh to adopt the annual budget that it
needs to be made available so is there
really any neces need to change the
dates because it already is required
that they give seven day notice or
um or they be made available uh the the
budget before they vote on it so is the
change of dates necessary thank you
representative yukela I believe it is
because it's a public hearing that this
language is referring to not the vote so
it would just be clarifying language and
you can see that in line not end of line
foreign
thank you Mr chair thank you Miss Oregon
for taking my question since you
represent all the counties uh even
though this is specific to Hillsborough
and Rockingham County can you speak to
how the it would
impact other eight counties please yes
thank you for the question
representative it would not impact the
other eight counties this part of the
statute is specific to only Hillsboro
foreign
seeing no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you uh on the
sign up sheet the blue sheet uh there
there are no no Pros no cons
and with that we will close the hearing
on hb203
[Music]
okay we have many many pink cards on
this that means that we have a lot of
people who are going to speak
um once the bill is introduced we are
going to hold everybody who has
submitted a pink card to three minutes
we are getting behind and we're going to
want to uh
get through this hearing so
I have a representative partial
yes thank you who will be introducing
good morning chair members of the
committee
thank you for listening to this bill
today
this bill will regulate the point of
sale distribution of single-use
packaging and the disposal of single
packaging waste Returns the authority to
regulate these waste to the respective
municipalities as they are best
positioned to manage their landfills and
transfer stations
the Salient point
is if we can keep allegedly recyclable
bags out of our trash flow then we will
reduce our transfer station costs
the transfer station in my town is
facing a steep increase in haulage fees
that will increase the transfer
station's budget by half again
that is this expense that we need to be
passed on to all the residents of my
community
and the same problem facing many
communities
I've been told that RSA 149m has
Provisions for allowing municipalities
to regulate waste flow
but I believe that this bill
indisputably States it in the chain of
authority
I've included a fact sheet
on this on a single you use plastic bags
though this bill does not single bags
out
I would prefer to leave the definition
of single-use broadly and the belief
that's for the communities to decide
what if any single-use plastic is
unreasonably contributing to their waste
flow
in anticipation of what arguments are
made on behalf of retailers
I must ask if you are serving as a
chamber of commerce are we serving our
constituents
most of the American people have made up
their minds and are and are close to a
four to one margin in favor of
eliminating these allegedly recyclable
plastic bags from the streets and trees
where they often end up
we have alternatives
I'm an avid use of canvas user of canvas
bags well there are times that I'm
making a purchase and find myself
without a bag and I'm glad that just
what all the stores I frequent have
paper bags as an option
Statewide bans exist in New York and
most of New England
the American recyclable plastic bag
Alliance ar-pba our lobbyists for the
pla for a Plastic industry and
interesting enough
they changed their name from the
American Progressive bag of lines in
2020 despite the widely known fact that
about one percent of plastic bags are
actually recycled
we know the stories for how the contents
these recycling containers that you see
in stores
are um typically tossed in the common
dumpster
and true or not the pervasiveness of
these stories must contribute to the
fact that these collection centers are
so frequently unused aside from the
green washing propaganda of the Plastic
industry
nevertheless arpba were successful in
defeating a Statewide ban in
Massachusetts and now what plastic bag
this bill
modestly does the same
I'd prefer to make a Statewide argument
agreement such as to exists in Vermont
and Maine and I am grateful that those
states in the uh to those States and
that single-use plastic bags are not
part of the waste that they sent in New
Hampshire landfills
this bill will let communities decide on
how best to manage their trash flow
rather impose half Solutions on the
state level
if we can get a sense of the will of the
people then perhaps further action may
be warranted
in conclusion
I ask you grant an OP
OTP to this bill
give the state get the state out of the
way of regulating municipal waste
problems
and I have faith the communities will
act in their best interests
I thank the committee for the
consideration of Isabel and I'll take
any questions
thank you for the testimony do I see any
questions representative Holland
thank you for taking my question so
under the language of the spell then
could a municipality ban single use like
water bottles
thank you for the question if the
community so decided that wasn't their
interest
um I could see that happening I can see
where that might be in their silver
public health concerns Beyond what's
going in the landfill as uh the leaching
of plastic means that on average most
yourself myself consume on average about
One credit cards worth of plastic a week
um and we have that really fully studied
the effects of that type of internal
consumption of microplastics
so uh a community may decide to do that
I can't say my particular focus is
single-use plastic bags I know a number
of communities including my neighboring
town of Keene have
tried unsuccessfully I've answered the
question you've answered that question
we asked about models thank you we have
a lot of uh representative Manchester
thank you for keeping be honest thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
for taking my question
um
would this enable the local
municipalities to come up with their own
creative solution to waste management
depending on whether they have a
landfill or not or recycled single
stream multi-stream different
communities have different so would this
help enable more differences in
Innovation or do you think this will
bring
some kind of a uniform understanding
I would hope that it would enable
numerous solutions that work for the
communities and their own individual
needs and uh on their own basis where I
live I have a transfer station in one of
my towns three rely on the uh County
Municipal and one uses Advanced Plastics
as part of their solution I can see um
representative again am I going on
you answered the question about enabling
thank you thank you for taking the
question based on the um language being
so broad
um
does
it does the
let's say the plastic wrapping around uh
toilet paper when you buy it at Walmart
they would be a you're saying that you
would Grant the local municipality to
ban the the the
Walmarts in that in that municipality
from being able to sell that toilet
paper wrapped in plastic and also if you
happen to buy uh uh at a neighboring
towns Walmart that same toilet the
toilet paper wrapped in plastic you
wouldn't they would be able to regulate
your disposal of that plastic bat the
the plastic wrapping around the toilet
paper and say that you can't put it in
your trash and so you have to like keep
it on at your house forever like I don't
understand what your
because of this being so broad is that
question is that would that be allowed
under this this uh broad language thank
you
um it's thank you for the question uh
you pick up an interesting point I don't
think any particular Community would
actually go up to Target Walmart toilet
paper but I can understand that if
Community decided to do something of
that effect
they would probably rather than having
all these plastic wrappers accumulate in
somebody's house they would probably
make Provisions within their local
community ordinances which they would be
free to do
is that a good answer is that this
answer awesome answer
uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this committee
struggled mightily with a similar bill I
think three years ago
um part of it was an outright Statewide
ban and part of it was enabling
legislation I see folks here today who
worked on that bill
one of the sticking points and this is
my question to you has to do with a
single-use plastic packaging of other
items in stores similar to what
representative yukela mentioned I work
in a grocery store almost every single
thing we sell is individually wrapped in
plastic whether it's degradable or not
um how would this affect a store's
ordering of product
if they're if this if the municipality
sell single-use Plastics single-use
Plastics in a cover a bottle of Zyrtec
they basically cover everything
how how would this language address that
thank you for the question
um
I don't think it would be anybody's
interest to do a complete ban of all
Plastics at this time
the reason being is that we do recognize
that many of our product products my
hamburger comes wrapped in plastic
um
many of our products come wrapped in
plastic and we don't get much of a
choice on that I think that might be
something that we might want to look at
in another bill uh however to answer
your specific question
I don't think it would be in a
community's interest to do a sweeping
wide plastic band as you propose I don't
think it would mean scarcity of product
and nobody wants to face that
uh could this mean we could perhaps find
better solutions to the future if this
is a first step I think possibly sell
that thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question could you confirm
puts the power to make this decision
because it comes under the section's
power and duties of Town's power to make
bylaws by the fact that it
the power is with regard to bylaws that
it would be
solely up to the select board in a town
that is a good question and to be frank
I don't have a good answer on that I
would be glad to get back to look into
it and get back to you if I may thank
you representative Gallagher
um so representative save this kind of
touched on this a little bit when she
was mentioning um
uh some legislative history but I wanted
to
um
or I want to kind of focus more back on
that part of it um so yeah it wasn't
just three years ago but also last year
too last year it was a house bill
1119 I believe it was that came before
this committee I was wondering if you
could tell us a bit about
um
how it it looks slightly different to me
could you um
tell us about how the language has
changed since last year's um House Bill
1119 if you yes this bill is based very
deeply on House Bill 1119 that did
appear last year the Salient difference
that I see though was that we're not
have the state supersede
the what perhaps which should be a
municipal decision and managing their
landfills
um
I think there are times when the state
is in a better position to decide things
I think sometimes in better position for
the municipality and this bill because
it focuses on that unlike last year's
bill I think it reflects the fact that
it puts me now in the state and the
municipality back into their proper
thank you representative Edward
thank you for taking my question
what type of expertise would a
municipality need to have both technical
legal Etc to implement this uh proposed
amendment
I can't say that they would thank you
for the question
I can't say specifically what that
expertise would be I do know that the
city of Keene did initiate a plastic
span uh that was superseded by the state
uh because we are uh what's wrong
because the state has a thought I'm
sorry
Dillons is one that would allow them to
do that I believe thank you but uh home
rule you know sorry thank you
um yes because home rule um it was
turned back I don't think it takes any
particular expertise beyond what already
exists within the uh County
Administration
follow-up Mr chair follow-up go ahead
and uh approximately what was the cost
to implement that program in Keene uh
the program was not implemented it was
uh turned back before it was actually
see no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony we're going to
call The Honorable Judith Spang I'm
going to remind everybody everybody now
is on a three-minute Time
when you see this wave that means your
time is about to be up thank you go
ahead
okay good morning I'm representative
ex-representative Judith Spang I was in
the legislature for 24 years as chair of
resources at one time and I've worked on
this project of this this topic for for
three hard years bringing in four uh
different bills relating to Plastics in
various uh iterations so I am well
prepared to answer any questions
I see this as a matter of responsibility
we know that Plastics are a huge problem
we know that plastic bags alone are a
huge problem and the state of New
Hampshire has failed to take any
responsibility for this problem all the
other states around us have bitten the
bullet and done it and we have somehow
been able to unable to do that and I
think it's time for us to to take this
seriously
it's clear that the legislature is not
keen on doing something Statewide so
what does that leave us with that leaves
us with Legend with individual
municipalities where tremendous solid
race problems
I don't think it's fair for us to not
allow them to take control of their own
Solid Waste problems
the um
I think that the the whole issue of it
being
enabling should make people have a
certain amount of comfort that the
people who are making the decisions at
the municipal level are taking into
consideration the fact that a
neighboring municipality may not have
the same regulations
and they may decide that they want
bottles they only want bags Etc et
cetera we should let them to make that
decision according to what their
individual problem is and what the
individual inclinations of the
businesses within that municipality
might be
um
there are other states that have kind of
tiptoed into this like in Massachusetts
they let into that municipalities do it
individually
um some of the large retailers didn't
really like it very much they wanted to
have it so that every all the states had
the same rules relative to their their
Outlets so that gradually began to
evolve into a more General band the same
thing happened in the state of Maine so
they have been through the same process
that we will be going through to allow
the municipalities to take the lead and
then the when the state sees that it is
something that is workable and is
acceptable to both retailers and the the
people who live in the communities then
they can begin to craft some legislation
that will take care of the problem
Statewide
as I began it's time for us to take
responsibility of this we know that the
plastic particularly plastic bags are a
huge problem we must be responsible and
do something about it if you just want
to start with plastic bags that's fine
with me but you know you would have to
get an amendment and I'm sure your
representative stavis knows this issue
inside and out would be able to help you
thank you thank you for your testimony
do we have any questions representative
Brown
based on the questions from the other
Representatives I guess my concern is
you know how do you implement this on
such a this seems like such a
wide-reaching thing and you've just
talked about the fact that plastic bags
are the most significant issue as far as
you're concerned something that you
think you can deal with why don't you uh
simplify the bill so that uh the
implementation could be more realistic
thank you representative
I didn't mean to imply that bags are the
most the most problematic I meant I
think that it's the most easily dealt
with you know people are used to already
putting their plastic bags into
recycling when they're at a grocery
store they're getting used to bringing
their own bags I think it's the most
approachable so it's the best way to
begin to work our way into it we have to
get the the cooperation of particularly
the retailers to begin to change the way
they handle their uh their packaging
I believe you already answered this
question we've got a lot of people to go
through so I'm gonna have to stop you
right there that any further further
questions
see you none thank you very much uh next
well hello Henry how are you
good to see you again
thank you much uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Henry vayu and I'm here
behalf of the New Hampshire lodging and
Restaurant Association which is
comprised primarily of a lot of locally
owned uh uh restaurant operators
and we oppose this bill and primarily
because uh the members really don't want
to see a patchwork
approach uh to regulating and
determining what happens with single use
products uh we come from the perspective
of takeout packaging obviously there's
take out patch a lot a lot of takeout
packaging
um with our members and if there was a
community to adopt one sort of a rule
with regards to tape out packaging an
operator like the Common Man family of
restaurants which has restaurants all
over the state of New Hampshire or a
great New Hampshire restaurants company
which has a T-Bones Cactus Jacks Copper
Door they have
operations all over the state if a
community adopted a certain set of rules
regarding takeout that would basically
dictate what would happen to all the
others because they they buy in bulk for
all their restaurants and to comply with
one Community
it wouldn't make sense to have have you
know a bunch of
different kinds of packaging that they
would order so it would complicate it
for a lot of those operators and for
that reason we opposed the bill
thank you very much for your testimony
do we have any questions representative
management thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question
um
the you know it's a large associations
and large businesses that use this
recycled stuff
want the market dictate if the Mark if
the plastic is not available for the
restaurant and the only choice they have
is the recyclable whatever
um one
would uh don't you think that would
shift it so if there's a partnership
with the big businesses so
um and again there's a lot of locally
owned uh restaurants uh not all of them
are the big business as you uh describe
um and there are you know limited
options with regard to take out
packaging
um some are more expensive than others
um certainly uh restaurant operators
listen to their customers I mean Common
Man family of restaurants has gone to
paper straws unless you request a
plastic straw so that's something I
think they've heard from their customers
so to your point I mean they'll respond
to the market and their Market are their
customers so if their customers want
something different and their uh you
know environmentally conscious they'll
see no further questions thank you very
much thank you uh before I call the next
witness I have a Michael Nork uh from
New Hampshire Des but it doesn't say Pro
or con are you all right so I'm going to
wait on you uh let's go uh next uh Nate
Grace
thank you Mr chair I will be brief
nature Grace for the municipal
Association we are in support of uh the
idea of expanding the authority of towns
uh
which generally and specifically to
regulating
um single-use packaging
um I do want to address a couple
questions that the committee had
representative power asked about who
under 3139 has the authority to create
bylaws bylaws or just another word for
Town ordinances and that would be the
legislative body so typically that would
be proposed by the governing body by the
select board and then we would have to
be voted on by town meeting
representative yokella asked about the
disposal side of things I would defer
entirely to Michael Nork at DES to to
talk about that because he's certainly
the expert in that area that's lines 13
to 14.
um and uh I believe uh representative
Howland um and manjapody both had
questions about
um basically trying to narrow down what
the term single-use packaging meant um
and I I would just recognize that that's
a broad term that's not further defined
in this in the statute so presumably
it would be narrowed down at the local
level if this Authority was granted to
municipalities I'm happy to take any
questions that anyone may have
represent of your color thank you thank
you for taking the question
um did I understand your testimony
correctly that you're that that
municipalities need to
um go get approval from the legislative
uh body uh for their adoption of bylaws
and that they're not able to
um enact bylaws over the opposition of
of the uh municipality the the
uh anything under RSA 3139 would have to
be adopted at town meeting
um or you know cities obviously city
council the one wrinkle with this
particular uh bill is that
there's already a statute RSA 149 M
which again Des can talk about
regarding how transfer stations work and
all that waste disposal side of things
so there's already Authority that exists
for disposal and there's more specific
Authority there so if you have specific
questions again I'd defer to Des on
representative man chaputi thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Grace for taking my
question
um and answering my some of my previous
questions
so nhma is supporting this because it
gives the local Authority
correct it gives greater local Authority
and follow Mr chair follow up thank you
you just alluded to RSA 149 m m and how
does this conflict or would it conflict
and to what extent would it conflict
again I would defer to Des for that
question
thank you Mr Grace thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Kevin Daigle and I'm with the New
Hampshire Grocers Association we
represent both the chain and independent
Grocery and convenience stores
I passed out some testimony that you
received shortly and I'll try and keep
my comments brief in respect of your
time we have a couple areas of concern
with this bill and appear today in
opposition to house bill 226. this isn't
so much a Plastics issue as it is a
local control issue as you're aware New
Hampshire currently is not a home rule
state and our members greatly appreciate
the ease of conducting business in New
Hampshire versus surrounding states that
do allow that local control
by allowing cows to impose their own
regulations Grocers and businesses in
general will be faced with the patchwork
of local ordinances this increases
confusion for both customers and
businesses alike and through high cost
of compliance unnecessarily increases
the cost for all parties
in addition to the confusion and
complexities this bill creates it also
sets a bad precedent it provides an
opportunity if passed to open Pandora's
Box and potentially allow for other
issues to come forward seeking home rule
this creates an even greater web on
regulations that businesses and citizens
would need to navigate
we've heard from proponents that plastic
bags are not recycled so they need to
regulate and ban them
just because a town bans bags doesn't
stop residents from going to a
neighboring Town shopping and bringing
those bags back to their town to the
house
members of the food industry take great
pride in the recycling and
sustainability efforts that they've made
over the years
for instance Grocers provide recycling
bins at their stores to assist in
recycling single-use bags which then in
turn are recycled into clothing
composite decking and other plastic bags
for these reasons we ask you to find
House Bill 226 in expedient to legislate
well done on the testimony one minute 40
seconds very sweet
seeing none thank you very much for your
good afternoon I'm Zachary Taylor I'm
the director of the American recyclable
plastic bag lines that was formerly
known as the American Progressive bag
Alliance we changed our name as part of
our sustainability commitment to
recognize the important fact that
plastic grocery bags are in fact
recyclable through the store take back
programs we have partnered with
retailers to establish I visited
recycling facilities of Our member
companies and seen truckloads of these
products cease
um could you please tell us if you're
for or against the Bill I'm here in
opposition thank you the proposal my
apologies
um a bit visited facilities where these
bags are brought in by their truckloads
processed into new bags and then sold
back to back to customers who then can
complete the cycle again and again they
are also recycled into other products
like composite Lumber decking playground
equipment railroad ties and other
materials uh we have significant
concerns that opening the door uh with
226 will create a patchwork of competing
local ordinances that are expensive for
businesses expensive for consumers and
disruptive to economies of scale
Massachusetts provides a great example
of what can happen if this allows if
this is allowed to go forward they have
153 separate local ordinances dealing
with carryout bags alone
in the city of Boston there are four
separate ordinances within the city
within the greater City Limits Middlesex
County their largest county the most
populous county has 40 different local
rules
an environment where food prices are
going up and up and up
requiring stores to switch to more
expensive alternative products will
increase prices on struggling families
one retailer in South Carolina facing a
similar proposal to prohibit plastic
bags noted that their costs would
increase per store by 250 thousand
dollars
those are expenses that will be passed
directly under consumers who are already
struggling
most importantly we've heard a lot about
litter and waste
let me be clear the industry does not
want to see any of our products disposed
of improperly but the data tells a
different story keep America beautiful
did a nationwide litter survey on
roadways and waterways across the
country what they found is that plastic
carryout bags like the ones that will be
targeted if localities are able to
create receive this Authority account
for 0.6 percent of items collected at
litter cleanup when we talk about the
waste stream
data from the U.S Environmental
Protection Agency shows that all plastic
bags and sacks combine so everything
from a plastic grocery bag to a chip bag
that could be banned under this bill to
a garbage bag that could be banned under
this bill account for 0.3 percent of
Municipal Solid Waste to suggest that
plastic bags are a major driver of
litter or waste flies in the face of the
data and suggesting that bills like 226
are necessary to help communities deal
with these very real challenges
flies in the face of the data
I just want to close and say we
encourage you to oppose this bill to
preserve several important things in the
state of New Hampshire one a Level
Playing Field for all businesses we know
Shoppers will travel outside of
jurisdictions to avoid costs they don't
want to pay this has lead to led to
decreased sales and job losses in other
communities
two consumer protection
consumers are facing incredible stresses
right now with high prices this will add
to their grocery bills whether it's
through hidden taxes or other fees or
being forced to purchase alternative
more expensive products that are often
still made from plastic regardless
regulatory surgery and uniformity across
the state as well these are all
important considerations we look forward
to answering any questions and
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony
representative Brown
just one quick question out of all the
bags that are produced these recyclable
bags what percentage are actually
recycled the U.S Environmental
Protection Agency estimates that between
10 to 12 percent of plastic bags get
recycled research from recycled back the
recycling authority of Quebec Canada
found that one of the reasons why that
number may not be as high as some people
would like to see we'd certainly like to
see it go up is that plastic bags are
highly reused around the home up to 77
percent of bags get reused for things
around the house like picking up after
pets or aligning Waste Paper bins at the
home cleaning out food scraps I know I
use mine when I travel to keep my shoes
and clothes clean as I move from state
to state
thank you
representative man chapudi thank you Mr
chair
um you answered part of my question
thank you for the 10 of the total bag
recycled and reuse
is not same as recycle where it
continues to stay in the environment at
some point it ends up in the lab
representative do you have a question
for these so thank you don't you
don't you think that it is ending up in
the landfill whether it's reused or not
so Banning use of in the distribution at
the beginning will reduce the
plastic bags one way or the other
recycled reused
uh
think I understand the question
representative what I would say to you
is that we're using a plastic bag allows
you to not use another plastic product
that is often thicker more plastic
intensive and contains less recycled
content
um so these household tasks are still
going to be completed people will find
products to do them with being able to
reuse a plastic bag cuts out on that and
to be clear we want to see bags recycled
but if they're not going to be recycled
they should be reused and then disposed
of properly
foreign
representative priests didn't see there
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
it sounds like that you are again
enabling municipalities to do this but
you wouldn't have any opposition for a
Statewide prohibition of plastic bag
single-use plastic bags as they do in
Maine and it's been very successful
question
uh we would oppose that as well plastic
bag Bans are ineffective in advancing
their underlying sustainability goals
because they're not a large contributor
to the litter waste or Marine debris and
they put unintended consequences on
families and Shoppers that are highly
expensive
um so yes we would oppose a Statewide
ban as well because
while states have implemented them they
have not been shown to deliver on those
concerns because the alternative
products often have higher environmental
Footprints higher emissions profiles and
are often still made of plastic but
can't be recycled whatsoever those
Stitch bags of the grocery stores are a
great example of that a follow-up Mr
chairman follow up thank you so what
you're telling me is these cloth bags
that I use every time to the grocery
store is more
dangerous to the environment and and
offer more impacts than a single-use
plastic bag that doesn't degrade
thank you representative uh I'm not
saying it life cycle assessment after
life cycle assessment conducted by
international government agencies and
universities here in the US have
compared the environmental impacts of
these products looking at the whole life
cycle what they find is that you need to
reuse these products substantially more
for example a cloth bag the New York
Times reported on this if it's made of
organic cotton you'd have to reuse it 20
000 times to have the same environmental
impact as a quote unquote single-use
plastic bag that's every day for more
that representative
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for taking
my question you just cited in response
to a previous question studies that show
that plastic bag bands are ineffective
can you cite those specific studies
please
research from the University of Sydney
evaluating California's plastic bag ban
found that
there's an increase in purchase of
plastic trash bags on that ban that have
a higher emissions profile and a higher
carbon footprint undermining any
advancement in the sustainability goals
of reducing plastic consumption or
reducing emissions follow up Mr chair
follow up
I believe that you um excuse me I
believe you're referring to studies that
were conducted in New England states you
referred to those
studies conducted in New England states
that showed the program to be
ineffective can you cite those studies
representative there may have been a
miscommunication I referenced a study
completed by recite Quebec which is the
recycling Authority for Quebec Canada
that compared the environmental impacts
of various carryout bags and also looked
at how plastic
bags are reused at the home I'm happy to
representative yokella
thank you uh kind of following up on
representative priest's question so
years it seems from your testimony that
you are
um
in opposition to Statewide ban but
definitely like even more opposed to a
patchwork
solution uh
is so you're more opposed to this than a
Statewide ban is that what I'm
understanding from your testimony to be
clear we are equally opposed to bans on
plastic bags at state level local level
representative Gilman we could also kind
of get close to wrapping this up yeah
just a short question in these Studies
have
um
the fact of the petroleum use in
creating a plastic bag compared to the
petroleum use of maybe delivering cotton
bags or canvas bags
uh thank you representative for the
question so so first I would note that
plastic carryout bags are traditional
film plastic bag that we're discussing
today that's made from natural gas to
byproduct of the refining process uh the
reusable stitched handle bags that
you'll see the grocery store for a
dollar or two that are still made from
plastic those are made from oil I'll
also note as it relates to that
emissions question uh the same number of
paper bags requires seven trucks uh for
the same number of plastic bags it
requires one truck stitched handle bags
while they're made of cotton canvas or
plastic are imported from overseas
they're not made here in the U.S
overwhelmingly so you can also kind of
Envision how much more the emissions
impact of all that shipping all that
Transportation all that weight combines
to create that sort of uh deficit that
needs to be overcome by reuse and a life
cycle assessment done by Clemson
University looked at actual consumer
behavior and found that most consumers
are not using these products enough for
them to be a more sustainable option
thank you
you're welcome
Mr
Mr chairman representative priests just
for the clarification and of the
committee members I would like to see
um a list of these studies before we
move on from Mr Kelly I'm just
interested to see the source and where
they're coming from I would say if Mr
what was the last name Kelly Taylor if
you
it yeah Mr Taylor if you are more if you
would like to provide those you're more
than welcome to provide those
representative I will follow up with you
with those studies as will I with you
representative Davis as well so happy to
share them I think they're enlightening
okay thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you all right uh last one last
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Michael Nork with the solid waste
management Bureau at New Hampshire Des
uh we are not taking a position on this
bill uh I'm here just to provide
information to the committee
um the question that seems to be most
relevant to our area would be about RSA
149m the solid waste management act and
how this how this bill would interplay
with the existing statute
um so one thing I just want to make
clear is that RSA 149 m17 already makes
it authorizes municipalities the
authority to create bylaws relative to
management of their facilities their
transfer stations their landfills
whatever the town Solid Waste Management
Facility might be so they already have
that authority to make bylaws about you
know management of the facility as well
as separation of certain waste types or
collection of waste types within the
municipality so while we're not taking a
position on this bill I just wanted to
clarify that that there is existing
statute that makes it pretty clear that
municipalities have the authority
relative to disposal and management of
waste I think what's novel with this
bill is that it also authorizes
municipalities to regulate the
distribution of these single-use items
uh with that I'll I'll take any
questions if there are any
represent of you Ocala
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
are you so in your your statement you
said that they are able to
um create bylaws
regulating waste um are they allowed in
the example that I gave before allowed
to uh restrict you from throwing away uh
like ban uh throwing away some plastic
uh bag or or some some other waste that
is that you're
um your home that is you know normally
able not not hazardous or whatever like
are they able to do that right now thank
you for the question uh representative I
I think what the statute RSA 149m
authorizes is the municipality to create
bylaws relative to use of their transfer
station facility
so if the transfer station and the the
management of that transfer station
decided that they didn't want to accept
plastic bags in the trash disposal
stream but they wanted to recycle them
they could create bylaws around that for
use of that facility I don't know if
that answers your question but I think
it's not it's not
it's not so much about generally across
the the community it's more about use of
the facility
short Fallout
thank you so yeah I'm you specified
um facilities run by the municipality
what about private
um if a private
um company wanted to accept plastic bags
would the municipality be able to put a
bylaw in that says you cannot accept
plastic bags or a plastic product under
the current rules but they might be able
to with this
um language because it's not it's not
it's uh not specific to municipality run
landfills or okay disposal options thank
you for the clarification um so under
the current statute it would be for
municipally run facility so the
municipality has authority over their
own facility
with HB 226 as I read it it says within
their Municipal landfills and transfer
stations so it would enable
municipalities to do basically the same
thing that they already have authority
to do
it would not and just to further clarify
it would not extend to uh privately
owned facilities within the municipality
under my reading but I'm not a lawyer so
I can't say definitively
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so RSA 149
m-17 as it exists right now
gives the municipalities the ability to
manage the waste already that's been
created would this uh
so this um legislation this bill will
enable
the municipality to channel the um
create origin of these waste correct so
managing at the source correct so this
will be an enabling
the municipalities to do so so the
management becomes more streamlined
correct thank you representation I think
that's an important distinction that
waste only becomes a waste when it's
something that's discarded or no longer
wanted whereas distribution of a product
is kind of at the very beginning of the
the life cycle so to speak or the
consumer life cycle so yes that is
correct that this legislation the the
the novel part of it would be the the
enabling municipalities to regulate the
distribution of those products at the
very beginning
and and that is a source of that that is
a type of what we would call Source
reduction which is eliminating waste
seeing no more hands race thank you but
uh very much for your testimony I don't
have any more pink cards on the sign up
sheet blue sheet I have
five against one four and two
taking no positions
with that we will close the hearing on
HB 226 and I will see you all back here
foreign
folks we're gonna get going
yes well you know I've got this here
whoops
representative Brown could you bring the
pink cards or
236 and the blue sheet
thank you
okay welcome back everybody we're going
to open up the hearing on HB 236
relative to condominium conversions
underwater and waste disposal laws and
Municipal ordinances representative
Faulkner
when you're ready
Laura's yours sir
I'm here to introduce and speak to each
bill uh House Bill 236
concerning subdivision regulation and
talk a little bit about the overall
statutory scheme here we
allow we uh
we allow municipalities to regulate
subdivisions
and uh
it's a I would like to call it the
Howitzer of a subdivision of land use
regulations
it's a fairly extensive
set of powers that the municipalities
have through the planning boards
to
control the shape and and uh
and in fact whether or not subdivisions
are allowed to happen at all it's a
uh
is provided
through
um
RSA 27674
the
planning boards can we'll look at lots
of land to determine whether they meet
zoning
and whether they meet such criteria as
whether the development is too scattered
or premature
um
similarly we provide for the Department
of Environmental Services to regulate
subdivisions
with respect to septic and and water
supply
again the purely powerful tool they can
deny
the development of new lots of the
determined that they do not meet
minimum standards for the ability to um
to deal with subsurface Wastewater
disposal
these are very powerful tools now
we regulate con Condominiums through our
essay 356b
um
we
have created for municipal Municipal
regulations we have stated that
the conversion of a development that's
otherwise legal to
condominium and form of ownership is a
non-event for land use regulation
purposes you can't treat
a condominium any differently from any
other development based upon the form of
ownership
essentially if there's no change in land
use a condominium conversion
can't be denied it's not subject to any
to the subdivision
control but normally the sub the
municipality has
now the definition of subdivision in RSA
674 for municipalities and RSA 482
um
pay for for Wastewater well some septic
control
is essentially the same a subdivision is
is taking a existing parcel of land
and dividing it into individual Lots or
Parcels for the purpose of
development lots are defined as building
parcels
if it's not a division of land it's not
a subdivision
the issue that this bill tries to
represent is that
Des has interpreted the definition of
subdivision to include a condominium
conversion when there is no change in
land use there is no division of land
uh it's just a change of ownership
um
essentially says that a change of
ownership doesn't change the septic
disposal needs it doesn't change the use
at all
and
should not be subject to denial based
upon
um the current standards
that might be applied to a lot in
question
again the the standards of the the
subsurface disposal standards are based
upon Lots
the capability of the land
the condominium conversion you don't
have any new Lots there is nothing
there to analyze
so it's it's
the the denial of
condominium conversions just because
they're changing ownership is really
outside of the statutory
scheme that the legislature has
established for regulation of
Condominiums and subdivisions language
here just tries to clarify that saying
that if it's only a subdivision if it's
only a conversion
only a change of ownership and it
doesn't involve creation of any new Lots
then it's outside the
subdivision control portion of the Des
regulation
now what this bill does not do it does
not change
municipalities the municipalities
ability to regulate subdivisions that
actually create new lots that is
unchanged
uh that's actually well controlled by
existing law and by
numerous court cases
and it doesn't change Des ability to
deal with actual subdivisions where New
Lots are being created
doesn't change their ability to deal
with new septic system installations
it doesn't change their ability to deal
with
increases in load such as by adding
units or adding bedrooms Etc
it doesn't uh
change their ability to deal with
replacement systems or with problems
when a septic system fails and pollutes
groundwater or nearby properties none of
that changes it's only this
ability to stop a condominium conversion
that has no other impacts
the
um
the statutory well
Des interpretation of 482 B2
really calls into question the this
overall statutory scheme
I think it's clear that we as a
legislature are the ones who determine
what the statutory scheme is we alone
determine what the legislative intent is
if
if the administrative agencies are
unclear on that then I think we need to
change the statute to make it clear what
the overall scheme is and that's what
this bill does
we've got to take questions
okay thank you very testimony do I see
any anybody have any questions of the
state for the rep
resentative stavis thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question can
you say a little bit about the the
reasoning behind the last sentence in
your change here which reads changes in
the hours days or seasons of operation
shall not be considered a change in land
use I mean what what if the condominium
is
converted for the purpose of multiple
short-term rentals wouldn't that have an
impact on load
well if it does then Des can regulate so
they can regulate any increase in load
but it would just need to show that
there's an increase in load that creates
a need for a new or upgraded septic
Disposal system
so all it does is it takes that out of
the subdivision
portion of the regulation that leaves it
in the you know the increased load so if
you go from
uh seasonal rentals to a longer period
uh in the septic load that would require
a change in the septic system that
treats it then that's still and So
within DS's ability to regulate
follow-up Mr chair
all about
give me the means of regulations that
regulation that Des has
because once the conversion is made and
once the property is now being used for
a different use other than housing one
family or two families
the horses out of the barn so what is
the power that Des has in that situation
so if if it's a if it's simply a
condominium conversion it's not a change
in Loose Change in use by our own
definitions by the statutory definition
of
that's in RSA 674 I mean I'm sorry RC
356b
this only
accepts or change or pulls out those
situations where there's a change in
ownership and no new building Lots
and again the the increase in load if
you go from two units to six dwelling
units
that's going to require a a permit
through the uh through Des right now
whether it's a condominium conversion or
not
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so my question
pertains to section two and you may have
answered this in your bill introduction
um line seven on page two my question is
why is land use and site plan struck
in light of the
well
the land use plans are
the site plan regulations are subject
the same subset of zoning regulations on
the ridge you have to have zoning in
place before you can
have site plan regulations so
um
and you know if there's
if there's a change in use in other
words if you um
or an increase in use of a property
site plan reviews in other words if you
have a 10 unit apartment building and
you're going to
20 units
that is going to require
a site plan review irrespective of the
of the subdivision regulations or
subdivision laws or subdivision
ordinances
um
the requirement for a site plan is not
doesn't trigger subdivision review I
guess is the way to say it that there
may be
site plan review that is not a
further questions
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman I guess along that
same line of questioning that
representative power and representatives
Davis had
I'm a little bit confused as far as what
type of reviews are required
to get this conversion permit or process
going
so right now if if it's a large enough
unit the Attorney General's Community
Consumer Protection Bureau
is involved in the
interregulating registering larger
Condominiums over over 10 units
uh that is more of sort of consumer
protection of people have the
information they need to
to
um to make an informed purchase
uh our existing tenants in an apartment
building for example being being
protected
so if it's if it's an existing non
either legal or non-conforming
use
then
um
and that's only a condominium conversion
we permit municipalities to
require or to have a procedure for a
special
exception
basically to determine if that if those
circumstances apply
if there is no other change if there is
no change in land use if there's nothing
other than just the conversion to
condominium ownership then it can't be
denied but there there is a process for
review under the special exception
process
so you mentioned that uh that the it's
not size restricted basically now by the
fact that you said you were referring to
over 10 units and then you were also
saying that there's a special use permit
based on this now that allows the
conversion
if the municipality so provides in their
ordinances
they can require a condominium
conversion
to undergo a special exception review
process
so but because of the other
uh because 356 B
uh we they cannot
treat that Pro that project any
differently because it's a condominium
conversion so he
in other words they can't deny it just
because it's
you're selling it to you know on a
condominium basis
uh
if it doesn't comply with the other
you know if it does something if it does
add units for example or if it does add
um
creates a you know subdivision by
dividing off a portion of the property
then of course it would still be subject
to the existing subdivision or
representative
thank you Mr chair sorry we've got a
planning board member here
geeking out on this I I was on planning
board for 20 years and I've represented
planning boards and and
well no they can well
subdivisions as the legislature has
envisioned them
in other words subdivisions of land into
different parcels
would still be regulated
under local subdivision ordinances the
same as they are now this doesn't affect
that at all
and actually I think right now if the
as a subdivision something that's simply
a condominium conversion that would not
would not pass muscles to the courts
because that's been
prohibited by the legislature through
Mr chair
um
what is the
change to the legislation seeks to solve
so the problem is that Des can in fact
in some circumstances must
deny
under the under their
regulations and their interpretation of
this law they they can and must deny a
condominium conversion when there is no
change in the land use it's only a a
economy of encouragement they considered
any condominium conversion
to be a subdivision
if it's a subdivision they do not permit
it if it's if it does not conform to
current standards for lot loading for
septic again this only applies
for lots that aren't on in the municipal
sewer system
so
you know there are standards saying that
if you have this many units you have to
have this amount of land depending on
what the percolation tests are the
um
in in similar factors and if it doesn't
meet those standards they denied and
then the purpose of that is to prevent
New Lots from being created that can't
meet the new standards so they get to
stop this in advance during the planning
stage before these things before these
lots are created
and I'm not you know that doesn't change
that's a good thing you don't want to
have people not be able to develop their
Lots
you only want to stop it before it
happens
same on the municipal side
this doesn't change that if there is an
actual division of land into New Lots
then it's still covered by Des
subdivision regulations it's this only
says that in this circumstance where the
only change is change in the ownership
then it's not a land use event that is
subject to the Des subdivision
regulations
if they deny if they deny the um the
conversion
nothing good happens for the public you
know the existing building continues on
it continues on in a different ownership
so whatever the septic system is
whatever the septic load is can continue
on until it fails or needs replacement
so
doesn't improve doesn't
preserve Environmental Quality or health
it just
penalizes the owner who now can't sell
seeing no further questions thank you
I think we're going to call Philip
so chairman turcott and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Philip Trowbridge I'm the manager of the
land resource programs at New Hampshire
Des
those programs include the sub
subsurface systems Bureau which is
regulates septic systems and subdivision
um so the department opposes this bill
because it would remove protections for
buyers of Condominiums and will lead
which could lead to some of these owners
losing value of their property
and it also perpetuates pollution of
lakes and rivers from very old septic
systems that would otherwise be
modernized as part of the subdivision
process
I think what I want to do is start by
addressing some of the introduction that
representative Faulkner gave regarding
the Department's authorities regarding
subdivision and also how we handle that
situation
um the statute as it's currently written
specifically gives the department
authority to regulate condominium
conveyances of property and this is one
of the concerns we had of this bill is
it sets up a separate issue which is
condominium conversion which in our
opinion
is the same thing and so you would have
two two different definitions of the
same thing one of which requires
subdivision regulation and one of which
doesn't
so I think that the question of does the
department it's not really an
interpretation that the department is
making
to regulate condominium conversions it's
what we see is clearly written in the
statute is our authority to regulate
the background on the whole reason why
the Department's involved with this I
think representative Faulkner did a good
an excellent job of introducing that
these regulations require an assessment
of the properties to be created to
ensure that each new property
can have a septic system that can
adequately treat the waste that is
generated
the reason for this is to protect the
buyers so they know what they're buying
and also to maintain water quality in
our lakes and rivers
I think the best way to explain why
condominium conveyances is something
that we need to look at is an example
so what's something we often deal with
is a lakefront property that was an Old
Camp
like a campground might have multiple
houses on it multiple cabins
on the shores of a lake
um it's got a single owner's owner now
it was developed a hundred years ago
before there were septic system
regulations or or subdivision
regulations
um the the question is what to do in the
septic systems in that property need to
be upgraded
these are normally substandard Lots
meaning they're too small for the number
of properties that are on them and the
subject systems that are in the ground
were put in before regulations existed
so they're normally quite a bit smaller
and most likely not very effective
so when one of those subject systems
goes into failure it needs to be
replaced by a new modern system at
meeting modern standards which is quite
a bit bigger
if these you know cabins or structures
are close together
there may not be the space to do that
without interfering with one of the
other cabins
so if it if there's a single ownership
of the property that owner could make
decisions about moving a cabin or
replacing a cabin or removing a cabin
if those con if those cabins are all
commit condom minimized and owned by
separate people
then you could end up with a situation
where the septic system for cabin a goes
into failure they need the space that's
occupied by cabin B to put in a septic
system cabin B is owned by somebody else
who may or may not be willing to give
them that space
and so cabinet the owner of cabin a
essentially has a property that they
can't occupy because you can't occupy a
house that doesn't have adequate means
to treat the sewage and waste
so that's why we think it's important
for protecting the buyers of these
condominiums that know what they're
getting when they buy it that they're
getting a property that
has the capability to treat the sewage
and waste if it has to be replaced
uh some people have asked me well is
this really just an old property thing
you know should what about a modern
multi-family house that that's purchased
or built now and it's got a septic
system that was installed according to
state regulations and
um it meets meets lot loading
requirements
uh in those cases we still think
um it's a good idea for us to have the
subdivision regulations the lot loading
calculations are pro forma it's very
easy because obviously it's met the
current standards but one aspect of our
regulations is that it requires
that the responsibility for the
maintenance operation and replacement of
the septic system be clearly established
in the condominium agreement
it's very much common sense and we would
like to think that it's you know that
would happen anyway but sometimes it
doesn't and it's important that we have
this regulation because the cost to
replace the system for a large
multi-family house is fifty thousand
dollars
and I think without it with that large
cost it can lead to conflicts among
owners if it's not clearly spelled out
in the agreement so that's another
and finally you know I'm from the
Department of Environmental Services you
know I've talked a lot about real estate
but really you know one of the other
issues here is water quality
uh we feel like this bill would be a
step backwards for protection of the
water quality of our lakes and rivers
considering that the high percentage of
the State of New Hampshire
population that receives their drinking
water from Wells
protection of the groundwater quality is
very important
for protecting Public Health
old cabins on the shores of lakes likely
to have poorly functioning systems that
do not actually treat the waste
exempting these properties from this
epic System review when there's a sub
when there's a condominium conveyance
would be a missed opportunity to protect
the natural resources that drive tourism
in the state
so in conclusion the department opposes
the bill we think the statute is worded
correctly as it is in its intending it's
serving its intended purpose
and we think that
um
the the fixes you know that while this
may uh be helpful to certain properties
for certain sales we think that it's not
good policy for the whole state and
would have unintended consequences if
passed
thank you
do we have any questions representative
Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so
to get back to a previous question the
problem this seeks to solve is a problem
for folks who want to sell these
properties and may not be able to sell
them because they would have to go
through this extra step of planning
thank you representative Davis for the
question
um uh that is one problem we've
encountered uh some situations like that
where there's a property where uh
selling the whole property would be a
challenge but selling off individual
pieces
would would be easier
and one of the things I didn't touch on
in my testimony is this issue of a term
called lot loading that you may be
familiar with it it's not aside from
just the size of the septic system a a
parcel of land depending on the type of
soil can only treat a certain amount of
waste and so if you have let's say a 10
acre parcel and you can only you can
treat 2 000 gallons per parcel per acre
you can you can do I'm not going to do
the math but you guys can do the math
there's a limited amount of flow that
can be treated on that property and
that's lot loading
RSA 45a
in statute says the department cannot
waive the lot loading requirements for
properties
and so if someone is now wanting to sell
one of these properties and they've got
twice the lot loading
of what is capable the law is capable of
handling
going through the subdivision review is
saying I'm sorry you can we can
subdivide this for you but half of the
dwellings are going to have to be
removed and that certainly diminishes
the sale price
of the property
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so your whole
objection to not the whole but your
primary objection to this bill is that
um
Des does not have then the proper
oversight to make sure that current uh
septic design is met for the condominium
use is that correct thank you
representative Brown for the question uh
I think that
would I think that is correct I you know
it's it's a simplification uh you know
the I'd like to go back to the reasons
why we feel that the subdivision
regulations are important for us to do
which is to make sure whoever's buying
the properties has assurance that that
property uh can meet the septic system
requirements for treating their waste
and also is protecting groundwater and
uh is it a true follow-up
go follow up
thank you Mr chairman so basically the
only thing that you're concerned about
the real thing that you're concerned
about here is making sure that the Des
has the opportunity to review
the site to make sure it's adequate for
the for the use is that correct that is
correct thank you thank you probably
restating it helped me
understand
representative manager Puti thank you Mr
Twitter uh thank you Mr Scott for taking
my question uh how would would it be
different if it was uh Municipal sewer
and water versus uh septic because it's
more regulated yeah thank you
representative mangaputi uh yes you're
100 correct I I failed to mention that
for a subdivision with Municipal Water
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm looking at the first page of the
bill lines 23 and 24 where it says
changes in the hours days or seasons of
operation
dot dot dot so with this type of a
change does would this not I think that
you touched it touched upon it in your
testimony it would in fact indeed have
an impact on lot load with regards to
the the the
Wastewater the the septic
additionally would this not also affect
the you know the wells in the water
table and that Supply with those types
of changes
thank you representative power and I
thank you for bringing this up because I
was making a note when you had the
discussion earlier to to touch on this
issue and I think this gets to the
question of uh changes in um you know to
short-term rentals and
I have a two-part answer and the first
part is in in in fact and in reality you
know a change in the amount about the
frequency of occupation of a residence
would increase the water use
physically
I need to say the second part
importantly is that
the way that we determine the flow that
we regulate for our structure is is not
based on the frequency of operation it's
based on the number of bedrooms or if
it's a restaurant the number of seats I
mean there's quite a long table of how
you calculate the flow
and so in effect for us we you know this
wouldn't affect the way that we look at
lot loading
but it is an issue and we do get a lot
of calls from people who are calling us
now and saying the property across from
me is now a short-term rental and it's
full every weekend with you know 25
people and isn't this over you know
violating your septic system
requirements and our answer is
they haven't changed the number of
bedrooms that's you know in terms for
our regulations it's still the same what
will happen is that if they are over
using the system the system will fail
and then the responsibility will be an
seeing none I have a couple of quick
ones for you yes um on line 20 and 21 it
talks about the condominium conversion
and on 21 it's talks about a condominium
conversion means and it goes on to I
assume Give a definition is there a
definition of condominium conversion
anywhere else in the rsas
thank you representative turkott I
um I do we our attorneys looked for that
and did not find one
and that was part of our concern is that
we did not think that there was a
difference between a conveyance and a
conversion in fact
second question
um
I know we're talking a lot about
lakefronts and water uh
water quality for you know
condimenting conversions around the
Lakes
would a let's just say a large
large house sitting on a small lot
somewhere that is not served by water
and sewer
if that was turned subdivided into
instead of going from let's just say
um
one single house to five condominium
condominium units with now actually more
bedrooms more
water usage and discharge for sewer
would that is that something you would
also consider a condo conversion and I'm
talking away from the Waterfront now I'm
just trying to get an idea of what this
condom minion conversion
or conveyance includes would you how
would you handle that situation nice all
right thank you for the question and I
think about getting it correct it's a
small lot with a large house
you know and then
um but then that house being divided up
in into maybe apartments and being
condom minimized and not on Municipal
sewer not on Municipal Water on a
private well in a septic system
um we we would be involved with that and
you know what they would be assured in
terms of flow is the current flow that
they have
uh so so meaning like
I guess if the concern would be that
someone's got a house that you know it's
it's a
you know let's just say it's being con
you know existing house with six
bedrooms it's becoming three two bedroom
apartments
you know uh just for example
um then the we they could maintain the
flow that they have even though they've
changed it's cheap form of ownership
they'd have to go through the convert
the subdivision process but even if they
didn't meet lot loading they would still
be guaranteed the existing flow that
they have
if they were to want to increase their
use like add a seventh bedroom
then if that met the lot loading that
would be fine if it didn't they would be
at least allowed to maintain their
existing flow totally understand that I
guess to be a little clearer would this
bill have any effect or change what you
do in that situation uh yes it would
it's the same situation as the if there
see no further questions thank you very
much for your testimony all right thank
you very much
next we have
Andrea lamaro
good afternoon thank you for this
opportunity uh to speak to the committee
I'm Andrea lamaro uh president and
policy advocate for New Hampshire Lakes
and I'm here today to testify in
opposition to House Bill 236
so New Hampshire Lakes I think first of
all I think Phil did a great job of Mr
Tober did a great job of presenting our
concerns specific concerns relative to
Lakes
so
um
New Hampshire Lakes were a Statewide
non-profit organization our mission is
to restore and preserve the health of
our Lakes
we represent about 2 000 individuals
about a hundred Lake Associations
Community groups and each of those
associations has
hundreds of of members as well
so I said our mission is to restore and
preserve the health of our Lakes our
mission up until last year was actually
to keep New Hampshire's Lakes clean and
healthy so we've changed that mission we
need to restore and preserve the health
of our Lakes
and I what I wanted to talk to you today
about is just the state of the health of
our Lakes
um
we can no longer pretend here in New
Hampshire that our Lakes are clean and
healthy there are some serious issues
they are facing some of you may have
heard about toxic cyanobacteria blooms
that's an issue of the legislature took
up last year and now has a has
commissioned Des to do a plan
to address those toxic blooms those
toxics blooms in our Lakes are caused by
um
a number of things but one of them is
nutrient pollution
so we're concerned that exempting you
know taking away the opportunity for Des
to weigh in on you know the septic
systems for these condominium
conveyances is really a missed
opportunity to find systems that are
fouling to work with property owners to
you know fix these failing systems and
to make sure that you know future
Replacements with associated with these
these properties and have adequate space
for adequate septic systems so failing
septic systems Leach nutrients into the
water into the groundwater and
eventually into our lakes and there in
the lake these nutrients spur on these
toxic
cyanobacteria blooms
so I'll save you the big science lesson
but a failing septic systems in outdated
septic systems are not good for Lake
quality and I just wanted to bring in a
little bit of data to let you know how
serious this problem is of toxic
cyanobacteria blooms we're seeing an
increased frequency and duration of
these toxic blooms in our Lakes last
summer this Department of Environmental
Services issued 46 Public Health
advisories for toxic blooms on 37 of our
water bodies and lakes
people were basically told to stay out
of the water to keep their kids and
their pets out of the water because they
could get really sick short-term
illnesses and also chronic long-term
illnesses
um a little bit more data here so our
state parks
um
that have beaches in total experienced
77 advisory days so people visiting
those state parks our residents and out
of state visitors you know 77 days total
last summer you know couldn't swim in
the lake that they wanted to go swimming
the average length of a toxic Bloom on
our water bodies last year was 25 days
one the longest Bloom the longest
advisory was 103 days
so um
these toxic blooms are not only
endangering the health of our lakes and
endangering
People's Health and people's enjoyment
of the our Lakes they're also
endangering endangering property values
um
in the past couple of years some Studies
have been coming out about the impact of
recurring toxic cyanobacteria blooms on
lakes and this data is showing that
property values can decrease by anywhere
from 5 to 25 percent
that seems like a lot but if you've ever
experienced a recurring cyanobacteria
Bloom you would get it and you probably
wouldn't would be concerned about you
living along a lake like that
and I just wanted to point out that our
Lakes clean and healthy Lakes bring a
lot to our our state you know for
recreation for our residents our
visitors they bring a lot to our economy
there have been two recent economic
studies
showing one show that Lake Winnipesaukee
our biggest lake is valued and hold on
one sec yeah could could we attempt to
keep the we're talking a lot about
volumes could we talk specifically about
this I know yes I appreciate that right
we need to wrap it up again yeah so
basically my point is just going off of
what Mr trollbridge said that we think
that you know this is a missed
opportunity what this bill is presenting
to fine septic systems make sure that
when they're failing and they are able
to be adequately replaced to help
protect and hopefully restore the health
of our Lakes
which is good for our citizens our
residents our economy property taxes all
of that so thank you thank you any
questions yes representative treeleven
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question
um how does this change in this bill
relate to the fact that we have a site
assessment study law in place whenever
property is transferred from one owner
to another
um
within 200 feet of the body of water now
that is a good question and my
understanding that this is is is
different in that it's you know
subdivision and condimentimized so yes
when an individual you know sells their
property there is a site assess you site
assessment nothing has to happen to the
system but I understand my understanding
is that this is a different situation
thanks sure
further questions I see none thank you
very much for your testimony
thank you Mr chair Nate Grace for the
municipal Association we oppose this
legislation
um mainly in a cost basis but there are
a couple technical issues I wanted to
point out to the committee
the chair asked a question about whether
it's a definition of condominium
conversion anywhere in the statutes
under the Condominium Act RSA 356 hyphen
B colon 3 Roman nine there's a
definition for conversion condominium
which is the order of words reversed
it's a different definition than is
provided here
representative power asked about page
two line seven uh Crossing out site plan
regulations
um I would note that that was something
we noted as a technical issue as well
because obviously slight plan
regulations are adopted under 674 colon
44. they're adopted by the planning
board they're separate from a zoning
ordinance which was adopted by the
legislative body of my town meeting
under 67416 so this would change exactly
what type of regulations would apply in
um and then finally under page two um
lines two through five
um currently the conversion of existing
properties tick Hondos can be regulated
by local rules if and only if um that's
provided for in the zoning ordinance um
which again is adopted under 674 16
and that Authority is found in
and that provides a definition of
subdivision which is different than the
definition provided in this bill so that
could be problematic depending exactly
uh how that
plays out because there's no
harmonization there and this bill
doesn't contemplate changing that
regulation as far as the main point I
want to bring up is uh just to build off
the example given by Des which is that
if you have a situation where there is a
conversion and the septic system fails
and there's no room for a new septic
system
um
what happens with that property and you
either end up with a situation where
it's not usable because there's no way
to get rid of human waste
or you end up in the situations we've
seen in some towns where they've more or
less been required to run a new public
sewer line down to that property and
that is a very costly Endeavor costing
millions of dollars requiring bonding at
the local level and it ends up costing
taxpayers quite a significant amount of
money and we are concerned that passage
of this bill could set up municipalities
especially along Lakes regions for a
situation where they would be required
to run public sewer lines to properties
along the lake which again would cost a
significant amount of money happy to
representative Manchester
never fails thank you Mr chair
um question
um this is in really from
how does this address the critical need
of housing in our state in different
communities not every Community has
public sewer and
water representative I don't believe
that has anything to do with this bill
do you have a question on Mr Grace's
testimony yes in terms of subdivision
wouldn't that be creating more housing
if not subdivide it
no because it's just a change of
ownership so you're not creating any new
buildings or anything
um and because there isn't that review
by Des you have a situation where you
might have
buildings that currently are able to be
occupied by residents which would no
longer be able to be occupied by
any further questions uh nature could
you just uh you said RSA 356 D colon
what was it b as in boy colon 3 Roman
nine
and it's conversion condominium so the
the words are reversed gotcha thank you
very much thank you questions seeing
none thank you very much for your
testimony I don't have any more pink
cards on this bill HP 236 on the blue
sheet I have one person signed in in
favor
and with that we'll close the hearing on
HB 236
and
We Now open up HP
265 relative to Municipal property tax
relief for installation of fire
suppression systems
and representative Burroughs I believe
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for hearing HB 265 which is
relative to um enabling Municipal
property really for the installation of
fire suppression systems
um this was a bill that was drafted in
direct result of a major fire that
happened in North Conway at the red
jacket in um you might have seen it on
television or in the paper in April of
2022 I was coming
back home from the south I saw smoke
everywhere and I saw heard on the radio
about it and I thought to myself this
there's going to be deaths here
miraculously
um there were two firefighters and two
civilians injured nuts and not seriously
um but the fire destroyed a huge section
of the hotel was which is a major
institution in our community we also
have a water park there so it draws a
lot of tourists
um
again as I said luckily there were not
fatalities but the reality was the
guests had to jump from balconies uh
from one balcony to another to escape
the impact of the fire in January of
this year Hunters shop and Stave shop
and Stave in in Wolfeboro was reduced to
Rubble due to a fire
um and again luckily for this one it
began 9 15 p.m and I believe no one was
injured but if you've been to Wolfeboro
the stores in the middle of town it was
fortunate that no other businesses or
homes were impacted and this is a major
institution in a small town that depends
on it many people depended on to buy
their their groceries so this bill
excuse me was drafted with the hope of
preventing such fires in the future
those of us who were involved in
drafting this bill quickly learned that
the Mandate of putting in fire
suppression systems for older buildings
was not an option because in talking to
small innkeepers in small hotels they
said this bill such a mandate would put
us out of business which was not
something that that we wanted to do so
[Music]
um
and again be and again because of the
high costs of these systems they're
astronomically high and again we did not
want to we did not want to put people
out so
um today automatic fire sprinklers are a
fire code requirement as of 1991 for
buildings that are not high rises but
older structures are grandfathered and
are not subject to this requirement so
this bill was drafted with the
assistance of Sean Toomey who is here
the State Fire Marshal who suggested
that RSA 79e the community fight
revitalization tax relief incentive
could be an option to help with a
Sprinkle retrofit as such it would allow
municipalities to provide local tax
relief for the installation of automatic
fire suppression or sprinkler systems
for qualifying instructors under the
community revitalization tax relief
incentive this program allows a
municipality to provide a temporary
period of limited tax relief for
property owners who wish to undertake a
substantial rehabil habilitation of a
qualifying structure which will provide
at least one public benefit the I think
the initial
um
intent of the of the of this this
section was to
um was for uh historic structures but
there are also buildings in our
communities that play an important role
like I said the supermarket and um The
Red Jackets certainly are important
structures in our community
um so as such we inserted an amendment
to RSA 79e2 by adding a qualifying
structure for the installation of
automatic fire suppression or sprinkler
systems and this would not include
dwelling units used only for residential
purposes
um the owner of a qualifying structure
who wishes to install such a fire
suppression system May apply to the
municipality where the property is
located for tax release relief the
municipality May Grant again is enabling
make and Grant tax assessment relief for
a period of up to five years following
the installation of a fire system the
municipality May determine that the
installation of such a system would be a
benefit to the community under this tax
relief incentive the qualifying
structure would for a period of time
determined by a local governing body
body get the property tax on a
qualifying structure which will not
increase as a result of the
rehabilitation or as in this case the
addition of the fire suppression system
so I'm asking you to support this bill
to help more more businesses hotels and
other businesses install modern fire
protections technology and will enable
it to keep its occupants in our
communities safe from fires in the
future
thank you very much
representative stavis
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Burroughs for taking my
question my question has to do with the
use of the word or in lines eight and
I think you may have just answered in
your in your testimony about historic
structures if that was what you had in
mind that's my first question and my
second question has to do with the fact
that do you have any concern that using
or as opposed to and
might result in people
converting buildings into warehouses and
putting sprinkler systems in them that
don't necessarily do anything for
Community revitalization but give them
tax breaks okay and just in regard to
your second question for I have a copy
of the bill that doesn't have for some
reason doesn't have the same numbering
as yours so I can't refer to that but I
happy to go back to that in terms of the
historic struckers that was the original
intent of the um of this incentive and
and um oh there we go
oh there we go okay do you want to ask
me that one again sure it's I line lines
eight
it's just the use of the word or instead
of the use of the word and
yeah I think that that's a good point
I mean I'd be up I'd be amenable to
amending that to Anne and again in terms
of the um in terms of the historic
structures that was the original intent
of um of this the community
revitalization tax relief as I said but
I think that we have structures in our
community are not necessarily enough
historic value that that provide a great
benefit for example a supermarket
representative treeleven
thank you Mr chair excuse me and thanks
for coming to testify I'm wondering
who's going to decide
um what a fire suppression system is
worth in a building and what portion of
that worth would go to the taxes
either to the tax relief or to the taxes
that would be charged after the relief
was done the
um that's a good question
um I would I would make the assumption
that the that the cost of the system
would be would be what we'd be looking
at in terms of the relief
um that let's let's just hypothetically
say that it was a million dollars on
what this would do is the municipality
could Grant relief in terms of you're
not raising the the um assessed value of
the property for another million dollars
for up to five years got it and the
municipality gets to decide that thank
you thank you
representative yukela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
is there anything in this that we're
that would limit them to the cost of the
um
the enhancement or and
um is there anything that limits them to
say
um determine that
having us more buildings with the
sprinkler system is there is in the
public interest and therefore any
business would be able to
to have this relief I know shouldered by
the the local
I I think you put in an application to
your municipality and they would make
that determination as to whether this is
no
representative bro
thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you representative hello
um on line 14 just like uh
representative yakala had said the the
process for his uh what type of review
would be done to uh Grant relief with
disco before the select man the fire
chief you know what what process would
be actually done do you have an idea on
that I'm not saying you do but I'm just
curious I don't I think that process
would depend on the meters probably
again there is an application they put
it forth and then they would they would
make that determination so this is just
enabling legislation to go along exactly
all right thank you
for the questions I have one quick one
um
it's kind of along the same lines
is it my understanding then that the
granting of tax relief I see it as maybe
being a little subjective is that the
case I mean is it
the individuals who are going to decide
how much and how long to give the tax
relief well their bill says is up to
five years and uh to my mind I mean like
I I use in the other example if you're
paying a million dollars for a system
you know that's a good basis to decide
you know is that enhance the value of
the property by a million dollars in
terms of tax relief
yes I understand that okay
as written they're really it's pretty
much open to interpretation I would
agree with that okay I would agree with
this
represent uh you Keller
thank you thank you for the for taking
another question is the
the
decision on who gets and how much
completely uh dependent on the governing
body and the actual taxpayers that are
going to have to subsidize this relief
are do they have no say in this under
under this law
well the municipality decides and they
are representing their constituents so
you know just like any other body makes
decisions on behalf of the taxpayers
representative Gilman Gilman gimme gimme
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um I'm very familiar with the 79e and
the governing body and making the choice
of how many years you get with this um
do you think this new change will
require re-adoption of 79a because
you're adding a significantly different
thing to it
I'm not sure this is an amendment to
that so I'm not sure I answering that
question a municipality has to adopt 79e
in the process to go through and the
number of years and public purpose Etc
um but this this change to me is
um
kind of substantial because it goes off
historic structures and historic
districts and you know kind of the aim
of reuse of buildings so my question is
in your opinion
um would this require municipality to
re-adopt 79e
I'd answered by saying again this is not
a mandate it's enabling so if they if
they choose to do this there's no
mandate for them to do so when we when
we insert this amendment okay thank you
okay
seeing no other questions thank you very
much for your testimony we have one
thank you Mr chair my name is Tom zotti
I currently serve as the fire chief and
Emergency Management director in
Wolfeboro
I've been in the fire service for a few
months shy of 33 years all of which is
with the town of Wolfeboro
um I'm not here today to talk about the
technical details of this I'd just like
to relate my experience with
sprinkler buildings and unsprinkled
buildings and so forth if I might
um I would like to start
by reading a few lines of a report from
the National Fire Protection Association
called U.S experience with sprinklers it
was published in 2021
sprinklers reduced the impact of fires
compared to reported fires and
properties with no automatic
extinguishing systems when sprinklers
were present the civilian fired death
and injury rates per fire were 89
percent and 27 percent lower
respectively the rate of firefighter
injuries per fire was 60 percent lower
fire spread was confined to the object
or room of origin and 95 percent of
reported structure fires in which
sprinkler systems were present compared
to 71 percent in properties without
sprinklers have proven to be reliable in
reported structure fires considered
large enough to activate them from 2015
to 2019 sprinklers operated in 92
percent of such fires and were effective
at controlling the fire and 96 percent
of the incidents in which they operate
it overall sprinkler systems operated
and were effective in 88 percent of the
fires considered large enough to
activate them
one sprinkler is usually enough to
control a fire and 77 percent of the
structure fires where sprinklers
operated only one operated and 97
percent five or fewer operated and 99 10
or fewer operated
that said I I think I hope at this point
we are not arguing whether sprinklers
are effective or not I think there's a
general consensus that they work
my experience in Wolfeboro as many of
you I'm sure aware we have a fairly
compact older downtown area and also a
relatively rural
um outside of town if you will
um
but based on our size we're roughly 6
400 under the the latest census with an
estimate of 18 to 20 000 folks
seasonally
um we don't see that many buildings
proposed or even
renovated or rehabilitated
that are large enough or of a type of
use that would trigger Fire and Building
Code requirements to be sprinklered we
do have them and we do see them but not
nearly as much as a Concord or a
Manchester or a Portsmouth perhaps
that said in looking back at the
statistics we mentioned earlier
um
in our smaller tend to be smaller
buildings as time has gone by and
maybe there had been a minor renovation
or a change of use or a new tenant or
something like that I've always kind of
made it my
mission to hopefully nudge the owner or
operator or at least have them think
about you know would it be worth
sprinkling this building nobody ever
argues sprinklers don't work they argue
they cost too much
it's always frankly an economic
consideration they're looking for as as
you well know return on investment or
over how many years will I see a return
on my investment what other
dollars and cents benefits will we see
from that
legislation like this I think in my
opinion
gives us one more tool in the toolbox to
make
to allow business owners and operators
to see the benefit
of
um
sprinkler installation particularly in
existing
structures
to be able to run the numbers and and
feel that it's a cost-effective
um
system to install I would point out too
that as I understand
on the federal level the cares act has
um
enabled business owners to use an
accelerated depreciation schedule
so my to my way of thinking the enabling
legislation at the local level plus what
might be available at the federal level
may be enough to put some of those
business owners who might be on the
fence
show them enough benefit to make it them
feel it's worth their while to
um
to install sprinklers I know Fire
Marshall Toomey is here and he can
probably go way far out further into the
weeds than I can on on some of these
things but to sum up
um I think this is just again another
tool in the toolbox to incentivize
business owners and operators to
do something that I think again we all
agree works it's just if we can bring
the cost to a manageable level it stands
to reason we'll see see more of them
um and at the same time as I as I read
it this would allow the the municipality
to decide
how much and and to some degree for how
long and what sort of form that may take
um and I think that is an appropriate
approach and I'd be happy to try to
answer any questions I might
thank you for your testimony
representative true 11. thank you thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question do you have um any idea as to
the insurance costs
for a building that is sprinkled versus
a building the same building that's not
sprinkled
I'm not in a position to give you
dollars and cents but I know as I've
discussed it with people over the years
um and I say that with the understanding
that the last few years may have thrown
off some of these numbers both on the
insurance side and on the construction
side right
um the numbers I would be here would be
and again I believe this was more in new
construction but it was a six to eight
ish year payback in terms of reduction
on an insurance premium versus un
sprinklered and and that sort of thing
again with current conditions and stuff
I'm sure that has changed one way or the
other perfectly fine that's all I need
at ballpark thanks representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so I'm a member of the engineers
Union I've been working down in Boston
for decades have you given any thought
to the load on your department with
testing these systems like monthly and
yearly if all of these systems were
installed as your department ready to
handle that kind of load
as a general statement
um we wouldn't be doing the testing the
business owner operator would contract
with with a company that would do the
actual testing we do in many cases
witness that testing and that sort of
thing
um it would take some
reorganization perhaps I don't I don't
see it resulting in necessarily having
to hire new positions or anything again
I'm going from my experience in the town
the size of Wolfeboro I obviously can't
speak for another municipality
um we do also currently for uh
routine maintenance and testing and that
sort of thing except the signed
documentation from the sprinkler company
as to what testing they did what the
representative man chaputi
foreign
looking the other way thank you thank
you Mr chair uh thank you for taking my
question you um spoke extensively about
the sprinkler system what about the
other fire suppression system how does
that benefit or
you know the bill alludes to that are
there other more efficient less costly
or more costly but more efficient system
uh
I think in general when we speak to fire
suppression systems I think the
assumption is we're talking about
building sprinkler systems obviously
there are more limited area
extinguishing systems if you will for
example in the ventilation Hood in a
commercial cooking operation and that
sort of thing I I as I read this again
as a
more a lay person when it comes to
legislation
um I mean I read that to the it it kind
of refers to sprinklers
um if uh this is written in a broad
enough fashion that it would include
um for example the the suppression in a
ventilation Hood
um it's something for a municipality to
consider but typically that is driven by
a code requirement either you have to
have it or you don't have to have it
um if it meets certain requirements you
would have to install the suppression
system
by the letter of the code I see this
legislation as benefiting a town like
Wolfeboro where we have those sir I
think you've answered his her question
uh representative Hicks thank you Mr
chair thank you chief for taking the
question
um simple question knowing the compact
nature of your downtown and
interconnected buildings do you see Town
leaders advocating for this as a benefit
uh I I think it would be a good subject
for discussion um as you heard
one of the sponsors earlier we did two
weeks ago have a significant fire in
town which has as you might imagine
resulted in some discussion
um I I don't want to put myself in a
position of speaking for the board of
selectment or anybody like that but this
has been obviously a topic of a lot of
conversation in the last few weeks
especially
um so my my
instinct is that if this sort of
legislation were enacted and that could
become
um a possibility it would certainly
um generate discussion as to whether or
not it was appropriate for wolfborough
to adopt a set of guidelines to to do
that I I would
um if this were successful I would ask
them to at least consider it again I
don't want to put words in somebody
else's mouth but we'd certainly want to
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so in regard to these
types of fires that you're talking about
you your department responds Lakes
Region Mutual Aid response how much does
that typically cost to respond to
something like that as opposed to you
know like the offset and taxes that you
would end up I I guess I'm not in a
position to give you actual dollars and
cents but as you can imagine
um
uh again I'll use the recent fire in
Wolfeboro as an example we I estimate we
had approximately a a hundred responders
to the scene and when I say responders
I'm not just talking about firefighters
who are most of our town Highway
Department was there to help us our
Municipal electric Department was there
our water treatment plant operator was
there when and you could have knocked me
over with a feather when he said we
can't sustain this we got to do
something different
um so if you take
that number of people
um many of the Departments around us are
set up similar to the way we are as
combination departments some full-time
people some part-time call or volunteers
and you start adding up those numbers
it's a significant number I really don't
okay seeing no more questions thank you
very much for your testimony I have no
more pink cards on the blue sheet I have
three who have signed in two of them
were
and Herring on 273 uh 265 is closed
opened up at hearing on HB 273 requiring
composting and waste recycling to be
foreign
second we have the wrong
okay representative Gallagher you're up
hi so I'm
uh representative Eric Gallagher from
Concord Ward 6 which is Meramec County
District 20. I'm here to introduce
House Bill 273 and that requiring
composting and waste recycling to be
made available
to residents of public housing
um
so this is a bill
I
um
a
brought before this committee last term
um
and we
were we ended up referring it to interim
study
because there are some more
work that need to be do done on it um
so yeah I had um but then we'd never
actually did the studying so my
intention was to um turn this bill into
a study committee for this this time
around but it looks like OLS didn't
actually do that for me
um
so
yeah I I did message them saying
um I want this to be a study committee
and they said yep we've got your request
we're going to do that but then it looks
like they never actually followed
through so um
yeah um
since this bill
isn't really what I asked for
um and I um I I would be perfectly fine
if you just found it Ito if you want
um and I'm not really going to spend
uh too much time uh defending it since
it's not what I asked for if the sponsor
I don't think we can do that today but
uh if that's the end of your testimony
and thanks representative Gallagher
um would another option be to say send
it to a study committee this time and
really have a committee or well yes
another option could be to vote to
retain it I think interim studies for
the second year of the term yes thank
you yeah
um
any further questions any nuns thank you
uh representative Gallagher did you fill
out a pink card no idea
thank you
thank you Mr chair and each praise for
the municipal Association
um any
any option that does not result in
passages written is perfectly fine with
me
um we do have an extensive fiscal note
on this bill as written and I just urge
the committee to look at that I'm happy
to take any questions
thank you
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you one more pink card we have
Michael I think they are there we go
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Michael norkum
with the solid waste management Bureau
at New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services uh
I guess the testimony that I was going
to provide is pretty much moot at this
point if the sponsor has decided to not
uh
thank you for your testimony
representative minchputi thank you Mr
chair uh thank you Mr nark for taking my
question uh the I know it's not in this
committee HB 300 would that bring in
uh
Waste Management to Across the state if
that goes through
thank you for the question
representative the there is another bill
that the committee may be interested in
it's HB 300
which seeks to establish a food waste
disposal ban for the State of New
Hampshire that would affect
primarily the largest commercial food
waste generators in the state with the
intention that that would create more
um
infrastructure and Industry in the state
to handle food waste for composting or
anaerobic digestion so that the
intention there is that that bill would
you know create more of an atmosphere
where composting would be more
accessible
correct
thank you
seeing no more questions thank you for
the testimony I have no more pink cards
and we will open uh on that one there
were no sign-ins on the blue sheet
we'll open up the our last hearing of
the day HB 237 relative to the date of
and we recognize
Vice chairman power
foreign
thank you Mr chairman an honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill 237 for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
and Greenville in Hillsborough County
District 36. there are three main points
that I'd like to make today first what
does the bill do second why is this bill
needed and third how does the bill
address the issue
first what does this bill do this is a
straightforward bill that clearly
establishes a date of assessed
evaluation for the purpose of
determining eligibility for certain
property tax exemptions namely exemption
for the disabled RSA 72 colon
37-b exemption for deaf or severely
hearing impaired person RSA 72 colon
second why is this bill needed under
current statute a property owner may be
eligible for these property tax
exemptions based on their income and
assets the application window begins on
January 1st and extends to the statutory
filing deadline of April 15th of the
same year
for the purpose of evaluating the
applicant's income statute clearly
defines the time frame as the prior
calendar year however for the purpose of
evaluating the applicant's level of
assets the time frame is at the time of
application
this results in a total of 105 days from
January 1st through April 15th for a
municipality to measure one's assets
clearly this creates an inconsistent in
inconsistency as well as unequal
treatment both within a municipality as
well as across the state
and third how does this bill address the
issue
this bill clearly establishes the date
of December 31st in the calendar year
preceding said April 1st for the
evaluation of assets this simple change
in the law will ensure that every
applicant within each community and
across the state is treated by the same
asset measurement date bringing both
consistency and fairness in
administration
lastly I will note that language has
been added to the affected statutes so
that if this bill were to become law
local re-adoption of these exemptions by
municipalities shall not be required
that concludes my bill introduction Mr
chairman and in the interest of time I
will defer any questions to a subject
matter expert that is signed in to
testify behind me thank you okay thank
you for your testimony uh next we'll
um
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
municipal Association uh I'm not the
subject matter expert that's Mr Meese
show he's still in the audience
um we do support this bill this is a
technical fix bill I want to thank
representative power for bringing this
bill and a number of committee members
for signing on to it
um
we support the concept of a consistent
date so all taxpayers are treated
equally no matter what municipality they
live in logically end of year makes
sense that's already in in the other
statute referenced so we think this is
this is a a good technical fix just to
clarify the law as it should be I'm
happy to take any questions but if you
have any assessing questions Mr Michelle
will testify after me
any questions uh representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
the the date of filing versus the the
end of year
um that what do you think
um there is a benefit for uh or maybe a
detraction of setting a set date
um
as far as let's say you inherit a
million dollars on January 1st does
is that
um is are there situations that this
um
uh could be problematic or is is it just
beneficial uh
you know enough that that it overweighs
the the possible negative ramifications
of of it being filed as of the date or
you know the assets of the date filed
if someone's really interested in in
defrauding the government I'm sure they
can figure out how to do so
um but realistically we do need a date
to
uh at which point we can actually
calculate what the government needs to
do on its side of things so
um realistically the the best option is
probably the end of the year because
that's when everyone's finances wrap up
that's when all of the the banks all the
investment companies they all do you
know the accounting of assets and that's
what municipalities generally look at
when we're talking about assets for the
purposes of tax exemptions and credits
foreign
no other questions thank you very much
thank you final pink card of the day Jim
Mitchell
good afternoon chair and committee
members I do have some written testimony
uh would you like me to just pass it
through leave it right just leave it
right there on the desk with the rest
we'll go um so my name is Jimmy schum
Chief assessor for the town of Hudson
New Hampshire uh I am in favor of this
bill uh currently the statute does not
lay out what date to use for net asset
uh calculation of net assets
um the practice has been a time of
application
uh nobody could tell an assessor they
were wrong to follow that way into him
in New Hampshire in Hudson we use we've
been using end of calendar year asset
measurement since I've been there nobody
can say that I'm incorrect in using that
either because the law is silent
um so this proposal is to set in law a
standard date as the prime sponsor said
and so people will be treated the same
regardless of when they apply and
long-state apply timely and also they'll
be treated the same from Community to
community
um
I really think that this is a technical
fix and will allow taxpayers to know in
advance how they're going to be measured
so if you're going through the year of
23 and you're looking at your assets and
you're wondering am I going to come in
below the amount or above the amount if
I know the date that I have to have my
assets out by
then I can plan accordingly I literally
have taxpayers tell me that gee I wish I
knew beforehand what what it was and I
said well if you called us we would have
told you our uniform way of doing this
is the end of calendar year
the statute uses net income measurement
for end of calendar year I thought that
using the same calendar or measurement
for assets makes logical sense
um and uh Nate Graves was was correct in
terms of ease for the taxpayer of
getting these documents
um Financial companies Banks Etc they do
things by the end of the month the end
of the quarter the end of the year so I
think it is ease of the taxpayer that's
applying that we use end of the calendar
year as well
that's the extent of my testimony
thank you very much
questions
representative yokella so thank you
um your last statement
um as far as like um
um assets being uh attributed at the end
of the month
um
it was very interesting and and
especially like maybe 401ks or something
along those lines as far as like if you
were trying to get it in the middle of
the month what is the actual value of
you know um may not be
is um as obvious
um or harder to get than a statement
um
is that is that kind of the stuff that
you're talking about as far as being
clear about which date you want to
um accumulate the ass you know the
numbers for the assets
and and that it's easier to do it this
way and so that's one of the main
benefits of of picking a day
thank you for the question
um that is one of the benefits of having
a standard measurement date that kind of
aligns with how the financial services
industry is putting out the statements
right so Social Security to shoot Social
Security Administration they give you an
annual social security statement they
don't give you one that I'm sorry that
does dealing with income but as far as
assets uh like you say it is easier to
have a defined date that aligns with
foreign no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony on the blue
sheet we had nobody sign in on this
seeing no more pink cards we'll close
uh next week I don't know if I'm not
sure if you got yeah you all should have
got it next week we have two days again
um Wednesday will be our final bills we
will actually wrap up our public
hearings next week probably ahead of
every other committee Thursday we have a
um
besides that
as soon as I turn off the mic Christy
could you ensure that video and audio
are off here in a few minutes thank you
and that'll wrap up today I'd like to
ask the Democrats to stay for a quick
five-minute caucus briefing by another
member so we'd ask everybody else to
foreign